- As you were talking earlier,
I could literally see
a giant bead of sweat.
- It's because I've got the
fucking sun staring at me,
and we don't even fucking have the AC on.
- [Connor] The price that we, you know-
- [Joey] Evian water spray.
Let's go!
(chill music plays)
- Hello and welcome to another
episode of "Trash Taste."
I don't know what episode
number this is anymore
because it's probably gonna
be out of order anyway.
I'm your host for today, Garnt,
and joining me once again are the boys.
You know who they are.
- What are you wearing, Garnt?
(everyone laughs)
- Okay, it's summer now, okay.
I need to bring the summer energy, okay?
I'm like channeling every dad
during a barbecue right now.
- You look like if Trevor
from GTA V got a tan.
(everyone laughs)
- Like a dad with one
too many camera lenses.
You know what I mean?
And you're like,
ooh, I don't know what he's
getting up to with these lenses.
You know what I mean?
- Dad that goes "bird watching."
(everyone laughs)
- Do you really need a 500 millimeter lens
that's like this long?
Like, is there a, come on.
- Plays GTA Vice City once,
okay, I've got it now.
- Goes to Miami once.
(everyone laughs)
- But how are you guys like
surviving Japanese summer?
Like, how hot is it today?
Jesus.
- It's like 35, I think.
Or yesterday was 35.
- You know what?
Let me start off with something.
I hate it when you can't
complain about the weather
where you're from.
It's like, you know-
- What?
- I said on Twitter, I was like,
"I can't, I'm dying, man.
"It's 35 degrees."
And then someone replies, like
(scoffs) "It's like 42 here."
And I'm like, that is not
something to be proud of.
You live in a fucking,
like, the actual sun.
Like, why are you bragging?
- I fuckin' hate that shit.
Like, no matter how hot
it is where you are,
and you could be fucking
dying in the Sahara Desert
or something, you get to
like the nearest town.
You're like, "Fuck, man, I
just survived the Sahara."
And someone from Texas or
somewhere would be like,
"Oh, how hot was it?
"How hot was it?"
(everyone laughs)
- "You didn't measure it?
"You didn't measure it?
"Why didn't you measure it?
"Is it hotter where I am?
"You little bitch!"
- No, 'cause what I've realized, okay,
like living in Japan has
made me change my opinion
because before-
- On what?
- Okay, so before moving to Japan
or before like moving out-
- Something totally unrelated.
- Actually it's not totally unrelated
'cause before moving to Japan
or moving out of England,
my favorite season was summer, okay?
I was the summer kid.
- We've discussed this
in the podcast before
and we were like-
- Have we?
- Yeah, or maybe it was just off camera.
- I think it was off camera.
- But I remember we
were like talking about,
'cause I think you and
I both like the winter,
like much, much more.
- No, winter's the worst season.
- Fuck off.
- Winter is the worst season.
- Maybe this has just
become a conversation
that we have every single
year the summer turns around.
And everybody's gonna be like,
"You guys spoke about this already."
I'm like it's in my head, shut up.
- No, because like, I
didn't realize that, like,
summers in England are
actually pretty good.
And that's why summer
was my favorite season.
- Well, how hot does it get in England?
- It's like 25 degrees Celsius.
- That's not summer.
- That's the thing, right?
That's the thing!
- No, no, it gets hotter than that, Garnt.
- It gets hotter for like one week.
- The summer before we left,
yeah, but that one week is pure hell
because the UK, we don't
have air conditioning.
It just doesn't exist
in homes.
- [Garnt] True.
- Yeah, the one time I went to the UK,
it was during that week.
- It's horrible because, you know,
at least in Japanese summer, it's like,
oh shit, walking outside.
Fuck.
It's way worse.
But you can just go in
any building anywhere.
And you're like, oh cool.
- Just instant hard nip.
- They've got the AC running
at, like, full blast.
Like, it's good.
- It's like a fucking
tundra inside the building.
- You have no escape in the UK.
It's like maybe the gym has AC,
the supermarket probably has it.
But, like, that's it.
Like, when you go home,
you're like (gasps)
"Put on the TV."
(Connor yells)
- Yeah, 'cause, like, what do
you do to cool down in the UK?
- Have like nine fans on you.
- So, you do have fans?
- Yeah, but fans don't do shit.
- Yeah, fans don't do shit.
- Fans are like-
- Fans just dissipate the hot air.
- Fans are placebos.
You're like, "Yeah, it's
definitely doing something."
You're like, "Why am I
still sweating so much?"
- It doesn't, because all it is is
just taking the stagnant hot
air and just moving it around.
- Yeah, occasionally I
just like, you go up to it.
I put my shirt over the fan, and I'm like,
"This is true cooling."
- That's the best feeling though.
Maybe it's a nostalgia thing
for me because growing up or
like spending my summers in Thailand,
you know, in Thailand we
would try to save costs
as much as possible, you know?
So, like the AC is always
like the last resort.
That's like when we are literally, like,
dying of heat stroke.
Any other time, it's just like,
"Come on, you can survive with the fan."
So, like, I spent most of my, like,
Thailand experience being
cooled down by a fan
and AC was just like, "Okay,
if we don't put the AC on,
"we're probably going to die here."
So, it's I think that's why it's, like,
kind of nostalgic to me.
Like, I kind of like the fan,
like, I kinda like the
feeling of the fan on me.
But I admit like, if
you're not used to it,
like, I felt sorry when you visited,
you and Aki visited us in the UK,
'cause you had to sleep in my room.
And we, that was like-
- There was one fan in there.
- There was a single fan
in like my entire house
and we're like, "Joey,
you can have the fan."
And I was, like,
I don't think it actually
did anything for you.
- It didn't do anything.
I was butt fucking naked in your bed.
I'm like, I'm still dying.
It sucked.
- It doesn't help, and it doesn't
get cool during the night.
- Yeah, I get like the whole, like,
fan being nostalgic though
'cause like I have that exact
same thing at my grandma's-
- Oh yeah, suffering is nostalgic for me.
- At my grandma's old place
in the middle of nowhere
in the mountains, we didn't have AC.
Because the house was too
big to have a single AC unit.
And, like, also all the
doors were always open,
so it was always with a fan.
But it's nostalgic.
Is it good memories though?
No.
(everyone laughs)
- I love just dying slowly.
- I remember that time when
I almost died of heatstroke
at my grandma's house.
Good times.
- You might be confusing
nostalgia to like PTSD.
- I don't know.
I like the feeling of,
like, I prefer the heat,
the feeling of summer over winter,
like, any day of the week.
- Why?
- I'm just depressed in winter.
Winter is just like,
even like dying in this heat,
I still prefer what I'm
experiencing now to winter.
- What happens to you in the winter?
- Yeah, what happens, bro?
- Winter's just the worst season.
- Like, a fucking "Game of
Thrones" character right now
going on about this shit.
- It is, it is the worst season!
Okay, okay, okay.
I think it's, like, scientifically proven
that people are less happy,
people are more happy with more sunlight.
- I disagree.
- I think it's literally
more healthier for you
to get more sunlight because
you are literally happier.
- But there is sunlight in the winter.
- There's like barely any
sunlight in the winter.
And okay, here's the thing that
depresses me the most, okay?
Especially if you're
working a nine to five job
and you have to commute to work,
you wake up.
You wake up maybe 7:00 AM or whatever.
If you have to commute long,
it's like 7:00, 8:00 AM.
You wake up, it's dark.
You go to the office at 9:00,
and it's still just like
the sun's just rising.
- I love that.
It's so fun.
- No.
- It feels great, it's
like you beat the morning.
It's like, okay, I'm ahead of it.
- You stay inside, you stay
inside literally all day.
You're just in the office
with artificial light.
You go out, it's 5:00
PM, and again, it's dark.
- I like that.
- I like the night.
- How could you!
How could you not want
any sunshine in your life?
- You know, most of the time
I have my curtains closed.
- Yeah.
It's too hot.
- Even in my office now, I
have them closed all the time.
- And like the second thing.
Everything's dead in the winter.
There's no color at all.
You look outside, everything's gray.
Everything's drab.
How can you be happy
with, like, zero color?
- I don't know.
I just think you're a boring person.
(everyone laughs)
- Like, literally the only
thing to look forward to
in winter is Christmas.
Like, I'm pretty sure-
- I don't give a shit about Christmas.
- I'm pretty sure they invented Christmas
because if they didn't have Christmas,
like everyone would just have
nothing to look forward to.
- Objection, I'm from Australia.
We didn't have such thing.
(everyone laughs)
- Okay.
- It's like this for me.
- Everyone knows that Christmas
was invented by Coca-Cola.
- Of course, of course.
- There was no Christmas before Coca-Cola.
Everyone knows that.
(everyone laughs)
You know, I don't know.
It's fun.
It's cozy.
You know, you get to-
- Yeah, it's cozy.
- Also, you get the most
drip in winter, you know?
- I agree.
- You get no drip in the summer.
- I wouldn't be wearing
this drip in the winter.
- You get the best drip
and you get the best sleep.
- Yeah, true, sleep is clean.
- I don't know.
- Crack the window open
a little bit sometimes,
it's kinda chilly.
- It's like, you're kind of like,
it's kind of like just, it's not cold,
but it's like a little bit like,
ooh, okay, maybe I could
put something light on.
But the moment you hop in that bed
and you put that blanket over you
and you're just wrapped in a warm cocoon,
there's like, I'm unstoppable.
This sleep is on my side now.
And you just get the best fucking sleep.
Yeah, the mornings suck.
- The mornings do suck.
- But for me, all the mornings suck!
I can't wake up in the morning,
so it doesn't make a
fucking difference to me!
- Okay, the only thing I will say is
that I can wear turtlenecks in the winter.
- Exactly.
- It sucks 'cause your options
are so limited in the winter.
It's like, you can't,
sorry, the summer.
You can't wear more than one layer ever.
Like, a jacket?
Oh, well that sucks.
No.
I love jackets.
Jackets are so fun.
- No jeans.
- Jumpers are gone.
Yeah, jeans.
I wear jeans still now, but I'm dying.
But that's because I hate shorts.
- But that's why like British summers
'cause what I realized is
that British summers is
just like a comfortable,
like it's a comfortable temperature.
- Pre global warming?
Yes.
It was good.
'Cause this didn't used to happen.
And it was never like this in
the UK where it was that bad.
- I remember we always
complain about British summers
to be, like, every British
person I've met is just like,
"Oh, you haven't
experienced British summer.
"It's like, really, it rains sometimes,
"it's cold sometimes."
I'm just like, it actually
slaps compared to other summers,
compared to other places.
- I would have agreed with
you until like two years ago
when for some reason two years in a row,
we just had horrible heat waves
that just ruined the summer for me.
'Cause it was always fun in the UK.
The best part about it
is I like it in summer
when the day is hot and
the night gets cool.
- Yeah.
- But in Japan it doesn't get cool.
- No, it does.
- No.
- I think it does.
Compared to now,
like, 'cause you know, it's like what?
Fucking 2:00 PM right now.
It's like the hottest
time of the day right now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But compared to,
you all right?
- Carry on.
- But compared to that,
when the sun finally
goes down at like what?
Like, 8:00 PM maybe,
and like around like 9:00 or 10:00,
it's like, it's pretty comfortable.
That's the kind of weather where I'm like,
"Okay, I'm really comfortable."
I can't concentrate with him.
- We're gonna cut.
- Mechs!
- You all right?
- What's wrong with you all of a sudden?
- I don't know, guys.
I just want to suddenly ride a mech
and battle other people to prove
that I'm the best mech pilot ever.
How can I satisfy this
sudden urge, you guys?
(everyone laughs)
- Well, I'm glad you've asked.
I've got just the thing for you, Garnt.
Mech Arena!
It's the new casual mobile game
shooter on Android and iOS.
Hop in your mech, play a game or two,
cause some chaos, and be
out in just a few minutes.
Anyone can play it,
and you don't need to be a
pro gamer to have some fun.
- [Joey] I actually tried it out
and I really liked the Guardian mech.
You can shut down enemy
abilities like shields or stuns.
and it forces the enemy to
completely reload their weapons.
With just a push of a
button the enemy is donzo.
- That sounds OP as F!
- It sure is, Garnt.
- [Connor] My favorite
mech is the Panther.
It has the ability called
the stasis barrier.
Put down invincible wall
that blocks enemy bullets
and slows anyone that passes through it.
If you'd like to maintain the distance
and snipe down your enemies,
this mech is for you.
- That sounds like a very cool mech!
- And even better, Garnt.
- No.
- Mech Arena sent us...
- What is that?
- A box.
- What are those?
Open it up, Joey.
Open it up!
- What are you waiting for?
- First of all, we got
to scan this QR code.
Once you scan that in, we
have these character cards.
- Oh, okay, look at that.
- Oh, I'm in like the room.
Meilyne's in there.
- How did you get that?
- It's actually kind of cool.
- So apparently there's a
poster that you can also scan.
- Oh!
Oh, that looks cool.
That actually looks cool.
- Well, while you guys are doing that,
let me check out some of the
other things inside this box.
Oh my God, this thing's so heavy.
So, I assume this is a Mech Arena coaster.
That's got some weight to it.
- [Computer] Mech Arena is a new-
(everyone laughs)
- It's like a birthday
card, but it's, like,
it's not only that.
It's like a legit screen.
- [Garnt] Oh my God.
- It's like an actual tablet inside.
And it just stops when you close it.
- Let me see that, let me see that.
Let me see that.
All right, ready for it.
Oh my God.
- That's actually so cool.
We have also what looks like
to be the Mech Arena art book
or a little art pamphlet that
shows all of the concept art.
I guess you can just keep the tablet
because there's even a charger.
- Yeah, I think so.
- To what I assume is the tablet.
I think we just literally
just got a free tablet.
Oh, and by the way,
that's not the coolest
thing that's in here
because there's also one more thing.
If I can even get it out.
We got a little figure.
- [Garnt] Ooh, look at that!
- A Mech Arena figure.
Look at that.
- [Connor] Now you can
finally get in the robot.
- And also we've got
the Mech Arena T-shirts.
- Where's my T-shirt?
- Where are our T-shirts?
- Crew, throw us a T-shirt,
a Mech Arena T-shirt.
- Assert dominance on the mechs
with these Mech Arena T-shirts too.
- I'm in the Mech Arena.
- [Joey] Mech Arena has
just launched globally.
They're running a huge celebration
event in game right now
with loads of awesome events,
as well as a great login reward program,
which you definitely
don't want to miss out.
- [Connor] It's completely
free to play right now.
And you can use the
link in the description
or scan the QR code here to
get one Black Carbon skin,
300 A-Coins, 50,000 credits
to help kickstart your game.
- And if you're lucky,
you might even get to
team up with one of us
and get to play a game or two together.
- I'm getting in the robots right now!
Back to the episode.
But, like, I like that.
I like having as much, as I said,
as much sunlight as possible.
And I just, I feel like the best,
like my favorite time period
of the entire year is about,
like, what's the word?
Like, dusk summertime when
like the sun's setting,
it's about 7:00, 8:00 PM,
and you're just watching the sunset.
Man, you feel like a
fucking anime character
'cause it's just like,
no, it's that fucking scene
where you're just like-
- Bullshit do you watch the sun.
- In every opening where, like,
the protagonist is watching the sunset
and the wind's just blowing.
- How often do you-
- You are not standing out
on your fucking balcony
being like, "That's a nice sunset."
- How often are you watching the sunset?
- [Navi] That's freaking
Star Wars you're watching!
- No, shut the fuck up!
No, it's anime!
Shut the fuck up, Navi!
It's not Star Wars!
- It's that scene on Tatooine
where he's like watching the sun go down.
- How often are you watching the sunset?
- Honestly, that's why I love my balcony.
That's why I have a hammock out there.
- Fuck off, you're not
watching the sunset every day.
- I'm not watching it every day.
- But that's the hottest
time of the day in my opinion
because you're getting that
like direct fucking sunlight.
- The hottest time of
the day is fucking now.
I can't stand out there
for like 10 minutes.
- It's hot until the sun goes down.
Like, the moment the sun rises,
it's the hottest time of the day.
- No.
I mean-
- I don't know, man.
I like going outside,
and I don't want to have
to fucking, you know,
shed away my life expectancy
just to go outside.
- Yeah, I guess that's
why for me in Japan,
I think my favorite
season is probably spring.
- For me, it's the autumn.
- Autumn?
- Yeah.
Like, around, like, October
is probably my favorite time
of the year just because it's like,
again, you have that
variance in drip, right?
You can wear a jacket if
it gets a little bit cold
in the night, but you can take it off
and, you know, rock a long sleeve.
But it's also not so cold
that it's excruciating,
but it's not too hot either.
- I feel like that's the
same as spring though.
And I like the whole,
have we talked about Hanami at all?
Like, the cheery blossom?
- I don't think so.
- I mean, like, so,
I mean, you know.
You watch anime, right.
You know what cherry blossoms are.
- The cherry blossoms!
- You know what fucking
cherry blossoms are.
- I won't lie, I was slightly disappointed
to find out the cherry
blossoms are only around
for like one week and then they fuck off
'cause I'm like, hold up,
they're in all the anime all the time.
What's going on with that?
- Yeah, they film all the
anime in the same week.
- I realize it's like a cult in Japan.
Like, they're obsessed
with this, the Hanami.
Like, everything revolves,
when Hanami's coming up,
everything is happening.
- Well, yeah.
- Like, everything has
to become cherry blossom.
It's like everyone just joins like a call-
- It's because there's a
really extensive history.
- Right, right, right.
But it's like, it's nuts.
Like, it's, I understand why
it's in anime so much now,
but when I got here I'm like,
wow, literally everything is decorated
like it's a Call of Duty gun skin.
It's like, everything's there.
It doesn't matter what it is,
it gets a cherry blossom skin.
- I mean, not gonna lie, man,
like a good Hanami is fucking dope.
- Yeah, but it's a bit
disappointing it's only one week.
What if you're like busy, you
got shit going on that week,
you're like shit.
- Wait 'til next year.
- I did miss Hanami this week.
- Yeah, this year, this year.
- Oh sorry, sorry, this year.
- I didn't do anything this
year, I totally forgot.
I didn't know when it was coming.
- I had one of the best
Hanami's this year.
- Rub it in, Joey.
Fucking hell.
- 'Cause we went to the
fucking Hakone for it.
All along the Hakone River's
just like rows and rows of Sakura trees.
- Want to explain what
Hanami is to the viewers?
- So, Hanami literally means
flower watching in Japanese.
So, it's basically this kind of,
I wouldn't even say it's like a festival.
It's more like an event that happens.
- Isn't it even a public holiday?
- No.
- I feel like it's a mutual agreement
amongst everyone to get drunk in the park.
That's kind of what it is.
- Pretty much, pretty much.
- But it's like,
because the Sakura are only
around for about a week
and maybe sometimes not even
a week, a couple of days,
people go out and like celebrate
by just sitting under a tree,
having a picnic under the Sakura tree.
It's fucking great.
- Do you think it's worth?
'Cause I know a lot of
people who are like,
"I want to come to
Japan during that time."
You think it's worth coming
to Japan just for it?
- I think if it's the first
time you're coming to Japan,
I think it's worth it.
- Yeah.
- I think now, because we've
lived in Japan for two years,
we're kind of like,
we're kind of like used to it.
But I feel like seeing
Hanami for the first time
and seeing like all
like the cherry blossoms
just like falling off the
trees and you have, like,
the ground is literally
covered in cherry blossoms.
Like, everywhere.
I think that's a pretty cool.
- Couple of weebs just
definitely just nutted
to you saying that right now.
"It's like in the anime!"
- Like, you literally walk through a park
and it is literally like
every fucking anime scene
where like the fucking cherry blossoms-
- Yeah, the cherry blossoms,
like, fluttering down.
Still looks dope.
- It looks dope as fuck.
I don't know what it is that
just is like so aesthetic.
But it's just the perfect aesthetic.
- I mean, Japan is like kind
of aesthetic all year round.
But I'd say like the most
aesthetic is probably
during the Sakura season.
- I'd say if you are gonna do it,
definitely get out of Tokyo.
'Cause like every single
Hanami place in Tokyo,
like, every single park that
has the cherry blossom trees
is crammed!
- Packed as shit.
- You will be,
like, 'cause two years ago,
we did like a small one.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And we had to get like a corner of dirt
in the park right next to the road.
Like, it was the only,
literally the only spot
left in this massive park.
- Where'd you guys go?
Like, Shinjuku?
- No, we were in Saitama.
- Oh, Saitama.
- And it was like, rammed as well.
So it was so full.
- 'Cause what people
normally do here in Japan is
during the cherry blossom week or season
or when they're blooming,
people go to the park,
they get like a kind
of like a picnic area,
and then they just get
fucking pissed in public.
It's great.
- I would say go like
when you come to Japan,
definitely do like a week in Tokyo,
and then if you're, you know,
if it aligns with the Hanami,
do a week somewhere else
where you can then celebrate the Hanami.
- Yeah.
- I feel like doing,
'cause you can't really
explore Japan in one week,
I don't think.
- [Garnt] No, you can't.
- You can't even explore
Tokyo in one week.
- True.
I've been here for like two years now
and I've barely explored Japan.
- How's Hanami in like Hakone you said?
- I mean, it's great because,
I mean, Hakone is still, you know,
very much a tourist destination,
but I mean, compared to like
Shinjuku or like Yoyogi Park.
it's like-
- Yeah, you don't get any space at all.
- No, absolutely no space at all.
And I mean, like, I guess as well,
like, in Hakone and a
lot of places in Hakone,
they have definitely like
positioned a lot of, like,
own-sans and like yocons
and stuff like that
around the Sakura
and like around all the
aesthetic parts of Hakone.
So yeah, it was great.
I mean, like, we stayed in like an Airbnb
that was overlooking like a
bunch of like Sakura trees
on the lake and in the distance
you could see Mount Fuji.
And it was like the most
like aesthetic fuckin' Hanami
that I ever had.
And I was like, you know what?
It's kind of worth to go all
the way out there sometimes
to just, like, get a little
bit of peace of mind.
'Cause otherwise it's just be like,
you'd be rubbing shoulders
with the person next to you
being like, "Look at the petal over there.
"Oh my God."
- It wasn't the people,
it was like the fucking
kids running around.
I mean, like getting pissed is great.
Getting pissed with like a bunch of, like,
five, six year olds
running around you, like,
playing football or whatever (laughs)
it's not exactly like
the best kind of vibes
to get piss drunk.
- If you're sitting like where I am now,
you are probably like this
close to someone as well.
Someone else's like mat and picnic set.
You said you stayed in an Airbnb.
Have you stayed in many Airbnbs in Japan?
- Not really.
- Yeah.
- I mean, 'cause like 90%
of them got fucking axed.
- Yeah, so for the Olympics,
the Japanese government changed
the rules around Airbnbs.
Basically just gutting them and making it
so that you had to make it,
you need to follow a lot of,
they basically made it so you
had to follow hotel rules.
Like, they had to have
like the fire escape
and like the floor lit up to the...
They basically made the
rules impossible on purpose
where you couldn't turn
a profit like reasonably.
- Basically, 'cause I
have stayed in an Airbnb-
- Yeah, I stayed in one as
well the first time I visited,
and it was super cheap.
You can get like, what did we get?
Me and Alan got the Airbnb for what?
Like, it was really cheap, like 150 bucks.
- But it was like a really,
really small room I remember.
- But it was right in Shinagawa.
- Oh!
Was that the one?
- That was the one I got really sick in.
(everyone laughs)
- The one you threw up in!
- What I want to know,
okay, so this was like,
I think the first time
you'd been to Japan?
- That was my very first time.
- [Garnt] Your very first time.
- I was so confused.
I just turned up in this place.
I had the instructions for this Airbnb
that I didn't understand.
I had my luggage and I was like,
"What the fuck is going on?"
I was so confused.
Like, the other side of the world.
- And of course Connor flies over,
and the very first thing we do
once Connor and Alan come
over is that we go to karaoke
and we stay all night.
- Well, we weren't going to.
So what happened was is that-
- I took you guys to an izakaya.
- [Garnt] Oh yeah.
- I was only gonna meet,
'cause you guys were like,
"Oh, we're too sleepy.
"We're probably just gonna go to bed."
And then I think me and Joey were like,
'cause it was my first
time going to Japan,
I was like (heavy breathing)
- Finally I can show this-
- I was like, "No, fuck this.
"I'm not resting, let's
go and get drinks."
- Yeah 'cause I was like jet lagged,
and so was Connor I think.
I mean, you were jet lagged,
but you were running on the
excitement of being in Japan
for the first time.
- I was like, "Joey, show me around.
"Let's go, let's go drink."
So then Joey took me
to like a very like...
- I took you to (speaks Japanese)
And it was during the week day
where they have 100 yen beers.
And Connor's mind was just fucking blown.
- I was!
- "A dollar?"
- I was like, "This is insane.
"This is like 60P."
- This is like uni prices.
- Not even.
Uni prices don't even get this low.
This was insane.
"This is beer, right?
"Like legit?"
- Legit beer, yeah.
- Yeah, we were drinking.
And then while Me and
Joey were getting drunk,
I think they, Garnt and-
- We had just landed.
- They were like, "You know what?
"No, we don't wanna miss out."
So, then they came and start drinking
and then we went out to karaoke.
- Yeah, we stayed-
- And I got very sick.
(everyone laughs)
- What I want to know, 'cause I know Joey,
Joey got very sick, if
you know what I mean
and had to stay around your place.
Who slept on the floor?
- Alan did.
- Garnt's editor.
And so this was November.
November, yeah, yeah.
No, January.
- I felt so bad.
- It was, like, basically
it was fucking freezing.
- Yeah, it was really cold.
- And we had to have the
AC running in the room.
Problem was is that there was a door,
there's literally no room
for anyone else to sleep
in this room except two people.
- Yeah, 'cause I remember
going to your place,
I'm just like, how the fuck
did you fit three people in it?
It's literally a shoe box.
- So, basically Alan had to
sacrifice his bed for me.
- And he slept in the hallway.
- Alan, the tallest motherfucker.
And by hallway it was
literally like just a single,
like, very, like-
- He just slept on the floor.
- It was like a human sized corridor.
You could not like fit anything more
than just like a fucking human.
- And it was like -5.
- It was really cold, yeah.
He was just like, like I,
'cause I wasn't aware that
Alan had given up the bed
and slept in the hallway.
'Cause I was out.
I was throwing up all night.
And it wasn't until I woke up that morning
and I kind of came to and I was like,
"Where the fuck am I?"
And then I saw Connor in
his bed on the other side,
and I was like, "Oh, okay
I'm in their Airbnb."
I was like, "Where's Alan?"
And then I just saw this
like lump in the hallway.
Just like, just this
lump of like blankets.
- He was so cold.
- And I was like, "Is that Alan?
"Is he dead?"
He literally slept in, like,
the fucking shivering hallway for me.
- He's that one friend
who's like the nicest guy
when you're like sick or
like when you drank too much.
He's always got your back.
I threw up one time and
even though he was drunk,
he cleaned it all up, and
I just went back to bed.
(everyone laughs)
- That was the very first time-
- First time I hung out.
First time I met him as well.
- First time you guys met, right?
- Yeah, and he cleaned up
my (laughs) throwing up.
That's how I know.
Like, from that point onwards,
I was like amazing friends with him.
'Cause I was like, this guy's got my back.
- No one else will do that.
- I would never do that for someone.
I'm like, "I'm going back to bed.
"You can deal with this tomorrow."
- I remember it was like
kind of like a house party
we had in England where we kind
of like rented out an Airbnb
and just like caught up with friends.
And you were like the new guy.
- I was like 20 as well,
so I was still like,
"Yeah, let's drink way too much!"
- I remember Alan telling
the story of like,
I think everyone was passed out
and it was just you and Alan awake,
and you guys were like sleeping
on the sofa or something.
And then like, I think he
made eye contact with you
and you made eye contact with him,
and he just started laughing
and then he just watched you
and you just like looked at him, laughed,
and just chundered everywhere.
(everyone laughs)
- That sounds like me.
I remember 'cause, what was it?
He made some drink with like
really budget energy drink.
And from that day on-
- Oh, Boost, Boost.
- I swore never to drink
budget energy drink.
Even energy drink is bad enough,
but the budget one
where it's like 50 cents
for two liters is like-
- What?
- It's like brake fluid.
Like, no wonder,
like of course you're gonna
throw up drinking that stuff.
I'm glad I did because I
didn't have to digest it.
- Exactly.
- Jesus.
- Yeah, we have a mate
from home who's now, like,
discovered a new cocktail
is what he calls it.
It's not a cocktail.
It's literally like,
okay, tell me how disgusting this sounds.
It's Boost.
So, a Boost energy-
- A budget energy drink.
- Budget Red Bull.
Boost and red wine.
- Oh my God.
That's, oh, Jesus.
- Does he have like
functioning like tastebuds?
- And I'm just like, I
thought we grew out of this
in university, man.
- That can't be-
- Not even uni students stoop that low.
- I think if you did that in
France, you'd be deported.
- Yes, Rick, I'm calling
you out right now.
It's disgusting.
Stop trying to get me to drink it.
- That's so vile.
- Ew.
What would that even taste?
Like, could you even taste the
energy drink at that point?
'Cause the flavor of red wine
is so overpowering, I feel.
- There's some things where
even if that tasted amazing,
I'm like, no, this is-
- Morally wrong.
- This is too broke for me.
Like, this is so broke.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
I just don't want to partake in it.
You could be broke.
- Nice follow up there.
- No, no, no, it's fine, it's fine.
It's not poor, it's broke.
It's different.
Broke is a mindset.
(everyone laughs)
- Poor is a lifestyle.
- Poor is your financial situation.
- Just don't be poor, just don't be poor.
- Being broke is the mindset of like,
I'm gonna live like an animal.
And I, you know, I don't
partake in that, you know.
- You can be rich, but be
broke at the same time.
- Listen, the reason why-
- If you're homeless, just buy a house.
- No, that's poverty, Garnt.
That's different.
There's a difference
between poverty and broke.
(everyone laughs)
Big difference, Garnt.
Come on.
Trying to get me in a corner
here saying being poor is bad.
Yes, it is, Garnt.
You want me to say it?
- You're not doing a
very good job of, like,
supporting your argument.
- Not my problem, not my problem.
- It's like being like,
oh, there's a difference
between being ugly
and unattractive.
- You can clearly afford red wine
and you can clearly afford energy drink.
Why would you mix them?
That is, like, you're making
yourself broke for no reason.
- Is that broke?
- That's broke, that's broke.
- I don't drink energy
drink period anymore.
I don't know at what age it
was where I was just like,
man, Red Bull kinds sucks.
- It doesn't do anything for me anymore.
Actually, know what?
I drink those, I don't know if it counts.
Is it an energy drink?
The Oronamin C.
- Oh yeah, that's kind of weird.
I don't know if I count that as an energy-
- I love those things.
- Yeah, it's like a vitamin drink.
- It's a vitamin drink that's
definitely not healthy.
- But it's in the same like
section as like Red Bulls.
- Oh, you mean the Japanese ones.
- It's like a glass thing.
It's got a really satisfying pop.
You pull this metal tab
and it, a really nice pop.
- Oronamin C, I think it's called.
- Yeah, it's this on screen.
- I don't know what it means.
- Definitely if you
kinda like sweet drinks.
I don't know who,
because I don't really
drink energy drinks,
but I love this thing.
- Yeah.
- It's so tasty.
- I feel that works better
than an energy drink.
I don't know if it's placebo, but yeah.
I mean, it definitely tastes
a lot better for my body
than a Red Bull does.
- I don't feel awful after drinking it.
- I think it was because
now it's gotten to the point
where if I have an energy drink,
it's literally going to
make me unable to sleep
for that night, and it
never used to be that way.
Normally I could like down
five energy drinks or whatever
and like be fine the night.
- See, I have the opposite problem.
I don't get anything from them anymore.
- That's 'cause you drink, like,
fucking five cups of coffee a day.
I'm not fucking surprised.
- Maybe.
I can quit any time, Garnt.
- Can you?
- I can quit any time.
- Said every drug addict.
(everyone laughs)
- I could stop any time.
- Just replace coffee with energy drinks.
- Yeah, exactly.
- "I quit coffee."
- I normally just drink a lot of tea
when I stop drinking them.
- Yeah, but tea also has caffeine.
- Not that much though.
- Doesn't tea have more caffeine?
- I don't know if that's an urban legend.
- Tea without, like,
the tea itself if you just eat tea, yeah.
- Oh, like, the tea leaves?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Eat tea?
- If you would just eat the tea leaves.
- Oh, okay.
- Like, if you would just eat it,
yeah, you'd be taking more
caffeine, but no one does that.
- The way you said that was so.
"Eat tea?"
- British people would be like.
(everyone laughs)
- It's not a drink, it's a meal.
- Scrumptious.
- Sure, if you just like,
fucking just like powder
the coffee on your food
or whatever.
Get a caffeine fix.
- At what age did you start caring
about what you're putting in your body?
- I mean, I still don't care.
(everyone laughs)
- What?
Yes, you do.
Fuck off.
- Okay, I care when I
can feel the effects.
Does that make sense?
- No.
- Yeah, yeah, I guess so.
- You mean, like, the immediate effects?
- Yeah, like if-
- Like, oh, I have a tummy
ache immediately afterwards,
I probably shouldn't put it in my body.
- Yeah, so like-
- I can just tell we're about
to get on an American talk.
You know what I mean?
Like, I feel like America's got-
- I wasn't even thinking that.
- I was already thinking about it.
- Connor was just like,
"I feel it, I feel it.
"My instinct is telling
me to shit on America."
- Why is your brain like all
the time just ready to reload?
- Sorry, sorry, go ahead.
Just carry on.
If it naturally goes that way,
it'll naturally go that way.
- No, like, there was a point I feel like
where you could just put
any shit in your body
and you could just not feel
any like aftereffects at all.
It would just like go away after a while.
But now, like, I have gotten
to a point where, for example,
I try to keep a healthy sleep schedule
because if I don't get a
healthy sleep schedule,
I just feel like shit.
I don't know.
I just felt like there was a point
when I didn't care about sleep schedule
and it didn't matter.
- Man discovers sleep for the first time.
- I think your sleep schedule, you know,
when you've got shit to do, that's-
- That's it, right?
That's it.
When you got shit to do and
you want to be productive,
like waking up late actually affects that.
And I'm just like, yo, I
never thought about this
when I was a uni student
'cause I did everything
at 4:00 AM in the morning,
and I still got a passing grade.
- That's what I'm jealous of
YouTubers who get canceled.
They just get to take a break.
They just get to like
fuck off for four months.
You know what I mean?
- Benefits to getting canceled,
you get a sleep schedule.
- I'm like, fuck off, man.
You canceled him.
He gets to take a four
month paid vacation.
His videos are still getting views.
This is gonna come back in five months.
David Dobrik got two month vacation.
That's all he got.
This is bullshit.
- So, what is the right amount of time
for like a YouTuber cancellation?
- I don't know, mate.
But the more,
when I saw David Dobrik and he came back,
zero repercussions.
His video that he came back with
got the same amount of views.
Dislikes and likes were amazing.
Got amazing likes.
You know, I'm like, this man
got a fucking month vacation.
This is bullshit!
And he got free articles about him.
He can get verified now on Twitter.
I'm kidding, he was already.
- As if he wasn't already.
- But I was like, what the fuck?
- He can get double verified.
- There was like, no repercussions.
And I'm like, wow.
What point is it like,
damn, getting canceled doesn't
look too bad right now.
- Don't ask for it.
- If Logan Paul can literally come back
from showing a dead body, I
feel like anyone can come back.
I mean, it's kinda the truth, you know.
- Mr. Anime said the same thing.
- Joey!
- I can come back from this.
- Joey finna get canceled right now.
- What?
For telling the truth?
- That was a joke.
Joey said a joke.
It is a joke.
Please don't cancel Joey.
But I was just thinking about it
'cause you saying that like, oh,
my mind made many jumps in logic there.
You were saying, oh yeah,
when you got shit to do.
But when you, you know, when you,
as YouTubers, you always have shit to do.
There's no vacations.
You can't just take a month off.
- People take a month off
for a "mental health break."
Which is like, I say with inverted commas
because it's kind of become a cliche now,
even though it's very important
and YouTubers do fucking need it.
- But you know, it's sad
'cause if you get canceled,
you almost get a better vacation
because there's people
still talking about you
while you're gone,
and people like searching about you
and making videos about you.
Like, I know this sounds awful,
and, you know, it's not great,
but you are still getting way more traffic
than you would be just taking a break.
So if you do something kind
of semi bad, you know, just-
(Joey laughs)
Do something light, you know.
Just do something like,
just, I don't know.
Just fart on a dog or something.
I don't know.
Just something that's, like, not too bad.
- Fart on a dog.
(everyone laughs)
- I don't know.
What's something that
you'll get backlash for,
but isn't really that bad
that you can just come
back from in a month?
You know what I mean?
- Give your cat vodka.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah.
She was perfectly fine.
Starting to think I should get a pet.
(everyone laughs)
That's a joke.
It's a joke, it's a joke.
- This is "Trash Taste"
getting canceled speedrun.
- I just thought about it.
And I was like, hold on a second.
All these people just get
like basically paid vacation.
This is bullshit.
- I mean, I think it's
like different severities.
- Yeah, people get like quite severe,
yeah, it's quite bad.
But I'm noticing more and
more, a lot of them just,
if they haven't really
done anything criminal,
they just kind of like
bounce back super easily.
- I mean, there are some people
who did criminal and still come back.
- David Dobrik's thing was
kinda criminal to be fair,
let's be honest.
- Yeah, it was kind of criminal.
- Endangered someone's life.
Came back all right.
Like, it just amazes me.
It's like, it's like,
Jesus Christ, a cult.
- But then there's like
examples, like EDP455.
And he's definitely not coming back.
- That man is never coming back.
- He's trying real hard
to come back though.
- EDP was a YouTuber who
got caught trying to meet up
with 14 year olds.
- Didn't he, like, try
to start his own website
or something?
- Yeah, he did.
- Did he actually?
- Yeah.
Because he got his YouTube banned,
and then he was like,
"Finna go to Facebook."
- You know it's bad
when Facebook bans you.
- And then his Facebook got banned.
- Yeah, Facebook banned him.
- So he's like, "I'm gonna
start my own website."
He's trying really hard, man.
- But yeah, the main point
of this whole me going
on this tangent was that yeah,
I feel like as YouTubers,
you don't really get a break.
I know we're complaining, oh boo hoo us.
Who cares?
I mean, we have an easy job, so, whatever.
But I mean it's yeah,
we don't really get like
set vacations which sucks.
And I kinda miss,
you know, one thing I
really do miss doing is
just being able to have two weeks off,
just play video games.
(Joey laughs)
Just catch up with shit.
Like, I don't even want
to go places anymore
'cause I travel anyway on like weekends
or whenever I find three
days here and there.
That's fun, but it feels like
you're still doing something.
But I just want that,
I miss that feeling of like,
I'm gonna take two weeks off,
catch up to all the movies,
catch up to all the manga,
just play video games.
You know, might start
Persona, probably won't.
Just buy it, just look at it.
- Yeah, so many games in my backlog
that I just want to play.
Like, the new Mass Effect
remaster got released,
and I'm just like, I want to play that.
But I haven't even played
Persona V Royal yet.
And fuck knows where I'm
gonna get the time to do that.
- I now have two wishlists.
I have the wishlist where I
will actually use the thing
and the wishlist where
this is just a wishlist
where it would be nice,
but I won't use it.
- Yeah, it's the canceled wishlist.
- 'Cause like you said you
had a day the other day
where you just woke up
and you did nothing,
and it was amazing.
- Yeah, I kinda just woke up one day,
and I was like, well, I don't
really have any like videos
to work on.
I don't really have any like
other side projects to work on.
And so I'm just like, you know what?
I'm gonna do a power move.
Not do anything.
Like, not do anything.
I didn't even like
check my phone that day.
I was like, no, phone turning off.
I'm just gonna do shit around
the house and just hang out.
And I was like,
damn, is this what like a weekend feels
for every other person?
(everyone laughs)
Like, I'm literally experiencing a weekend
for the first time in my life.
I was like, oh my God, this is fun.
I should do this more often.
Fuck.
- Like, I think for us,
especially the last few months,
have just been super fucking busy,
with us building this set
and having to like film a
bunch of episodes to get ahead.
I remember we had like
this two week period
where it was like, we
finished building the set,
and then we'd film a "Trash
Taste" episode every day
for like, it was like,
we have recording session
with either "Trash Taste"
or like a Netflix shoot or some kind of,
some kind of other live stream
every day for like two weeks
without any breaks or
weekends or anything.
- That was brutal.
- That was like, I was
like close to burnout.
- I do fill my schedule a lot on purpose.
- Like, I'm jealous of you.
I'm jealous of you the most
because you view streaming
as a downtime.
And I'm just like, I wish
my downtime could be work.
- I wish I could get paid for my downtime.
- Like, I wish I could
be paid for my downtime.
- I just enjoy it.
And that's why people
always complain to me.
Like, "make a stream schedule."
I'm like, nah, bro.
'Cause I just do it whenever
I want, but I still,
I stream often.
Around the same times.
But people are like-
- Yeah, why do you need a stream schedule?
You literally stream like, what?
Three or four times a week?
- 'Cause I think to
myself, most of the time
whether I decide to stream
is normally on the day,
that's normally like
if I've worked too much
or maybe I want to just chill out.
You know, maybe I got too much work to do.
So I don't want to do it
'cause the moment I
commit it to a schedule is
when it's work.
- Exactly.
- If I say I have to stream
it this day, it's work.
And then that's where I
won't start having fun.
- Well, I mean, like, I guess for you,
it's like good because
you have that one game
that you can stream, which
you also just play casually.
- Yeah, I think when you-
- Chess, right?
- No.
(everyone laughs)
It is right now.
But like I'm, you know,
I'm like, so I mean.
- [Garnt] Probably by the time this out,
you would have found out the
winner of the Tournament Arc 2
which we are currently a part of.
- Yeah, 'cause we are
recording these in advance
'cause me and Garnt
have had to go to the UK
as we've mentioned.
So yeah, we're quite far ahead right now,
but yeah, we're in the
middle of a chess tournament.
So, been playing a lot of chess recently
and really enjoying.
But yeah, no, I mean, it is,
I think when you are streaming,
it is very helpful to
have at least one game
that you can come back to
when you're like running out of ideas.
- I think that's what I'm currently trying
to find right now is that
one game where I'm just like-
- The problem is my one game
that I've just played a lot is
just, like, not very popular
and whenever I play it-
- Shadowverse?
- Yeah, whenever I play
it, everyone's just like,
"Oh, he's obviously doing this
"'cause it's a sponsored stream."
And I'm just like, "No,
I just enjoy the game.
"No one fucking plays this
game, but I'll play it."
- I did notice that when
I started playing Apex,
'cause Apex is probably the
game I've streamed most,
that my viewership was quite
much considerably lower
than normal, but I was
like, "Well, no, fuck it.
"I like this game.
"I'm gonna keep playing it."
And then after time it actually
like went up to the point
where if I stream new games now,
it's normally lower than Apex.
'Cause I've built up like the following.
You have to stick through it.
- I feel like you also
got very lucky as well
'cause Apex did just have
a massive boom in general
because of like every V-Tuber
under the sun playing it.
- Apex Raid of Shadows.
- Yeah, Apex Raid of Shadows.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, I don't know why that
was not even intentional.
I was just playing it,
and then I started seeing
every V-Tuber playing.
I'm like, whoa, what the fuck?
- See, that's not gonna
happen with my comfort game.
'Cause my comfort game
is about 30 years old.
- What's your comfort game?
- Like, any Final Fantasy game.
- Oh yeah.
- So, I'm just like,
I can't like fucking
stream Final Fantasy VI,
even though that's one of my
favorite games of all time
because no one's gonna fucking watch it.
And it sucks, you know?
- Well, would you even want
to stream your comfort games?
- I mean, yeah, because
I think like, again,
it's like Apex with
Connor where it's like,
it's just a comfort game, right?
Like, you don't necessarily
have to see it as work
or like you don't have to
necessarily be like entertaining
and wacky and goofy
and, you know, trying to hold an audience.
Like, you can just play a game casually
as you would normally do
and people would just be there
to watch you play it, right?
- It's different.
It's very different to my
normal streams as well, I'd say.
Depends on what I'm doing.
- You're a lot more quiet
during your Apex streams.
- Yeah, definitely.
'Cause I'm focusing on the game.
So, it's like I talk in
between stuff happening.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So, it depends on what's going on.
But that's why like I like
talking to Japanese people
on there 'cause it's fun.
- Yeah, I'm trying to find more
things that I want to watch.
That's like, I feel like I'm more like,
I like doing passive things
rather than active things
a lot of times in my downtime.
Like, the other day, like a few days ago,
I ended up watching all of
"Loki," the new Marvel series.
It's actually really fucking good.
Like, I'm not that invested
in the Marvel franchise,
so I was just like, oh, I'll
just put on one episode,
just see what it's about,
and I just ended up
binging the entire thing.
And I was just like,
this is fucking amazing.
It was only six episodes,
but every episode is 40 minutes long.
So, I basically just binged
an entire season of anime.
That's how I think of things.
- But it wasn't anime.
- But it wasn't anime, and I'm just like,
damn, why can't I do
this with anime anymore?
Fuck, man.
I missed that so much.
- So busy now where I like
dread good stuff coming out
'cause I'm like, fuck, I gotta
find time to watch this now.
- See, if only you could
like watch "Loki" on Twitch.
(Garnt laughs)
Just use that as your downtime.
Just have people watching you.
- Honestly, I would love
to have watch parties
with like different things I'm watching,
but obviously DMCA shit-
- Obvious reasons.
- Obvious reasons, can't do that.
But like, 'cause like I know Sydney,
her downtime thing is that
she watches horror movies,
and I don't know how she finds
so many fucking horror movies
to watch.
I didn't know this many
horror movies existed.
She watches at least three
new horror movies every week.
At least.
- The cesspool of horror
movies is like never ending.
It's actually insane.
- 'Cause I was never, I'm like,
I was never big into horror movies.
I don't really like horror movies.
And I assume you guys
aren't big fans either
'cause none of it showed
up on our three by threes.
Not a single one.
- There's some good ones, but it's like,
it's not my favorite
genre that's for sure.
- But she somehow finds so many-
- "The Shining."
- Huh?
- "The Shining" is really good.
- "Shining" is good.
I like "The Shining."
There's only a few horror
movies that I really like.
"Shining" is one of them.
I've really, 'cause like,
my taste in horror movies
is really niche I think.
'Cause I like kind of Lovecraftian horror.
'Cause I don't like the usual,
like, you know, jump scares,
ghost, paranormal stuff.
- Well, that's the problem.
So much of horror is jump scares.
- Yeah, it is.
- It is cheap and reliable.
- I think that's why I'm
such a big fan of, like,
Junji Ito and stuff like that.
'Cause it's really like,
the horror that I like
is really just the ones
that really unsettle me.
- Macabre horror.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm exactly like that.
Like, the kind of like Asian
horror is like definitely
more my taste in horror.
'Cause again, it's like,
you see like, you know,
you watch one "Paranormal Activity,"
you've basically seen them all.
- How the fuck did "Paranormal
Activity" get so big?
- It's because Steven
Spielberg greenlit it.
- Is that true?
- So I actually read up on it
'cause I had the exact same thought.
I was like, I saw fucking the trailer
of a "Paranormal Activity 73."
And I was like, how?
Why are there so many?
- But I remember when it came out,
I was in school and everyone was like,
"This is the scariest movie ever.
"So scary."
- Yeah, I know, right?
And everyone was like
shitting their pants over it.
I remember 'cause I was
in university at the time.
And so I was like, all right,
I'll see what the hype's about
because back then my
roommates had a watch party
and then we watched "Paranormal
Activity," the first one.
And everyone was like jumping
at just like the fucking closet opening.
And I'm just like,
I can literally see the
fucking string being used
to open this fucking door.
How is this scary?
What is going on?
- One remote press.
- I watched one that I thought wasn't bad.
What was it?
"The Invisible Man."
It wasn't that bad actually.
Is that what it's called?
- Oh "The Invisible Man."
The one about the-
- Invisible man.
- Sydney showed me that one.
It was all right.
- Yeah, I quite liked that one.
I watched it in the cinemas.
Pretty good.
I enjoyed that one.
- I watched the other day,
I finally watched, what is it?
"Hereditary."
- Oh.
- How was that one?
- 'Cause I missed out on
it when it first came out,
so I kinda missed the initial hype on it
because I was like, eh, western horror,
it's whatever for me.
But then I think Felix
showed me "Midsommar,"
which is done by the same guy, Ari Aster.
And I was like, okay, this is very creepy,
but also kind of cool and experimental.
So I was like, all right.
I heard "Hereditary" was pretty good.
I watched it.
It's weird.
I almost wouldn't even
call it a horror film.
It's like, I don't know.
You know what it feels like.
It feels like if David Lynch
made a horror film, you know?
- [Garnt] Okay.
- Where it's like, it's scary-
- As we established in the
previous three by three,
Joey, the big art snob.
David Lynch.
- I feel like you just,
to make a good horror movie,
you have to be fucked up.
- Yeah.
- Just be completely fucked up.
- To make any horror content,
I feel you need to be
fucked up in some aspect.
- Actually me and Sydney watched,
we had a night the other day
that we just kind of like
binged part of, like,
the "Final Destination" series.
And the reason for that was
because I kind of
remembered my very first-
- As a teenager, I loved those films.
- Yeah, yeah.
I remember the very first time
I watched "Final Destination,"
and it was actually in school.
So I think it was like,
I think it was like
middle school at the time.
So, I was like, I think
around 12, 13 years old.
And I don't know if the
same thing for Australia,
but you know, like, at the
end of term in school, right,
it's kind of like a free for all.
And the teachers, it's
kind of like that period
where it's like the last
two classes of the year
or something, teachers just let you do
whatever the fuck you want.
Was that true in Australia?
- I definitely think, it
depends on the school, but yeah.
I think most schools, it
was kind of just like,
"I'm going on break in
fucking three days, whatever."
- Yeah, so it was just like,
in the school that I was in,
you just had a week period
where you just basically go to class
and every teacher would put
on a different film or like-
- Just roll in the TV, right?
- Just roll in the TV.
And everyone would watch a different film
and like fucking 90% of
the time it was "Shrek."
It was fucking, it was
just always "Shrek."
- I was about to say, we
watched "Shrek" like every year.
- Okay, good, good to know that
that was just a nationwide thing.
- It's that time of year again.
- End of year, all right.
I guess it's "Shrek" again.
And I remember this one class,
one of my classmates brought in a DVD.
Because we were just,
because the teacher would ask,
what does everyone want to watch?
And so this guy, Samuel,
he brings out the DVD and he
brings out "Final Destination."
And he was like,
"This is a film I think
the entire class would want
"to watch."
And everyone's like, "Yeah, sure!"
- How old were you?
- I think we were like 12 at the time.
(everyone laughs)
- That is scarring for a 12 year old.
- I had not heard of "Final
Destination" at the time,
but we were like, "Yeah, sure."
Like, 'cause, like, you know,
anything to get us away
from "Shrek" or whatever
or whatever the usual
films we were watching.
He was like,
"Miss, I think the classroom
would want to watch this."
And nobody kind of like opposed it.
And the teacher had never
heard of the film before.
So, she was like-
- That's dangerous.
- [Garnt] So she was like-
- This boy just had this DVD on him.
- I think he knew what he's doing.
And so the film starts
off in "Final Destination"
and characters are,
like, I don't know what the
rating was like back then,
but characters were already swearing.
But I think in PG films in like the UK,
even if you have like
one or two swear words,
it can still be skewered
towards like the lower ratings
if it's just like one or two swear words.
- I think so, yeah.
- Yeah, so like characters,
so I remember the opening
scene where the, like,
get on the plane and people
start arguing or whatever,
it's kind of sus because
you can hear people
obviously swearing and
the teacher's just like,
"Samuel, is this suitable
for this age range?"
He's like, "Yeah, Miss, don't worry.
"It's just the opening scene.
"Don't worry, Miss.
"Don't worry about it."
And she's like, "Okay, okay."
So, I remember the opening
scene is where, like,
I think it's where the plane crashes.
That's the first "Final Destination."
I remember (laughs) so, a
bunch of 12 year olds are
just watching this plane take off,
and then obviously the
plane starts to crash,
the wing snaps, and
everyone's fucking screaming.
It's terrifying in the scene.
And then you see like blood splatter,
and then you see someone
getting burned alive
and (laughs) immediately, like,
the teacher gets up
aggressively gets off to the TV.
Doesn't even switch it
off, unplugs the TV.
And goes, "Samuel, get outside now!"
And that was my very first experience
of "Final Destination."
- Absolute Chad Samuel.
He was like, he probably walked
out was like, "Worth it!"
(everyone laughs)
- I remember one of them put,
like, it was in art class,
I remember this.
And like the teacher was
not tech savvy at all.
And he put Meatspin on all the PCs,
and then took it, just
unplugged all the mouse
and keyboards.
And the teacher's having
a mental breakdown,
didn't understand why
he couldn't just like,
he was like fucking
hammering the keyboard.
Like, why wasn't it turning off?
And then started hitting the monitor,
and turned the monitor off.
I don't even think he
knew how to turn it off.
And then he didn't know
how to turn it off.
He didn't even think of
unplugging it or anything.
So, this was still playing the whole time.
And then goes and gets
another teacher to come.
And he's like, "Why
don't you turn it off?"
He's like, "Oh, I didn't know how."
He presses the button to turn it off.
- Classic Meatspin.
- Meatspin, and it was like
these poor girls as well.
I'd never seen it.
- Don't look it up if you
don't know what that is.
- 'Cause obviously we're all like 12.
Every guy had seen it.
We're all like, "Yeah, you seen Meatspin?"
If you're a guy and fucking idiot.
(everyone laughs)
- I mean, it was like
Meatspin, Lemon Party.
- Lemon Party, Goatsey.
- You didn't know what Goatsey was.
- I didn't know what Goatsey was.
That was obviously like a few years past.
- Garnt, what was it?
You came in the office like, what?
Like a month ago?
And was like, "I just
found out what Goatsey is."
And we were like, "Oh, how
did you find that out?"
How did you find out?
- How do you find out
about Goatsey in 2021?
- You guys were the ones
who told me about it.
- Were we?
- Yeah, it was like literally
recording a "Trash Taste."
And you were just telling-
- Why was I talking about Goatsey?
- In an episode?
- No, this wasn't in an episode.
It was like before we started recording.
- You didn't know what it was?
- No, I didn't.
- And we were like you don't
know what Meatspin was,
you don't know what Goatsey was?
- I had to explain to
Garnt what Goatsey was.
- Please don't look it up.
It's some man spreading his butt cheeks.
- It's 2021.
You don't need to know what
Meatspin is or Goatsey.
- It's all just like websites
of people doing horrible things.
- Yeah.
Pretty sure we can find way worse stuff
on the internet now anyways.
- Oh yeah, of course you do.
- But back when we were growing up,
this was just like the shit
you like show your mates like.
- "Hey, there's this really cool thing
"if you Google Meatspin.
"Two girls one cup."
Two girls one cup is still
scarring to this day.
- Yeah.
- I remember watching that.
- Yeah, going back to horror movies.
Like, I would like to find...
A horror movie I really liked,
has anyone seen "Annihilation?"
The one with Natalie Portman in it.
- I've heard of it.
- That sounds so familiar.
What happens in this?
Give us the plot breakdown.
- So the plot breakdown is
that there's an alien artifact
or some artifact from
space that crash lands
somewhere in the world, obviously,
and it creates this kind
of force field barrier.
And you can easily enter the barrier,
but you can't get any
like electrical signals
or any like communications.
- Who else does this feature?
- This features Natalie Portman.
- And?
Is it Hawkeye?
- No, you're thinking of "Arrival."
- That was the one, fuck.
- Which I really like "Arrival."
- I heard that was good.
- That was good.
That's not a horror movie though.
- I thought it was.
- It's just a sci-fi.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, I just want more sci-fi stuff,
which I think is why I
was really into "Loki."
And so, (coughs) and so they
can't get any (coughs) sorry.
They can't get any signals in there,
so they don't know
what's going on in there.
And every team that they've sent in there
just never finds their way out.
So they literally don't know
what's going on in there.
And this force field is
slowly, slowly expanding,
so eventually it will
cover the whole Earth.
So, they need to kind of stop it.
They need to kind of figure it out.
And so they send this team of scientists
to go investigate what's inside there.
And I kind of won't spoil it from there
because a lot of-
- Sounds good.
- A lot of weird things happen,
and it's not,
so what I liked about
it is it was just, like,
really, it's really terrifying,
but not because of any jump scares.
Just some of the ideas
within this, you know,
some of the ideas of what
happens to the people
within this circle are
just like really unsettling
and really terrifying.
It is very much like a kind
of like Junji Ito ideas
where it's just really weird
kind of ideas that you don't,
you kind of have to have, like,
I don't know what kind of
minds you need to come up
with these things, but it's that,
I would like more horror like that.
And I dunno where to start
with recommendations,
which is why, if anyone
knows any, then I'm all open.
- What was that film with Nicholas Cage?
And there's like numbers and there's a kid
who like has the number-
- "Knowing."
- "Knowing?"
That's the one.
- I don't know how I remember.
- That's the one.
Have you seen that movie?
- Yeah, I've seen that movie.
- What is it?
- I can't remember.
but I remember it being really stupid.
(everyone laughs)
Nicholas Cage, like, he like
stops like a plane crashing
or something.
- No, no, I think, 'cause
I watched this as a kid.
I remember he, I think it's like-
- This needs to be a series
where we just try to
poorly recollect movies.
Like, what's this movie I watched?
That movie where like this thing happened?
- Okay, okay, I'm gonna
try and recreate this movie
from what I remember.
- How do you remember this perfectly?
- Because, okay, so as
a kid in the summer,
this is going on another tangent now.
So, my summers consisted
of me going to Thailand
and me spending like
six weeks in Thailand.
And obviously I wouldn't have
something to do every day.
So, like part of my
childhood experience is going
to the mall and just like
in basically every
Southeast Asian country,
there'll be these stands
where you have these like
DVD covers and you just like,
you just like flip through the covers
and just choose which
movies you'd want to see.
And some of them weren't
out on DVD yet officially.
So you just flip through
them and you just want,
I want that one, I want
that one, I want that one,
I want that one.
And then they'd ask you
to go walk in the mall
for like a good half an hour to an hour.
And then they'll call you.
And tell you when your purchase is ready.
Which was 100% totally legal of course.
- We all know that Southeast Asia has
very strict copyright enforcement.
- Yes, yes, yes.
So, like, my summer would
just be basically watching
every blockbuster Hollywood
movie that came out that year
because that, I looked forward to it
because I could literally pick every film-
- To this day, "Knowing"
is still the best.
(everyone laughs)
- And to this day, I
still remember "Knowing."
That's honestly why "5O
First Dates" almost went
on my three by three because
I'd watched that so many times.
- I thought you were gonna
say because of "Knowing"
or something.
I was like, what does
this have to do with it?
- There's only one movie
that tops "Knowing."
"50 First Dates."
- Yeah, so like I've watched
so many of these films,
which are now what I classify
as like airplane films.
'Cause now I would not watch
them in any other circumstances
unless I was on an airplane.
But "Knowing" was one of the films
that I was stuck inside
indoors in Thailand,
had nothing to do but just watch films.
And from what I remember, it was the,
I think it had to do
with like a time capsule
that was buried ages ago.
- Oh, right!
Yeah, that was it.
And there was like a number,
like, a cipher or something.
- Yeah, there was some kind of cipher
or something that like that,
like, predicted the
apocalypse or something.
- Immediately sounds dumb.
- And Nicholas Cage was just
like, "I see the future.
"I see what's going to happen."
- "The numbers!"
(everyone laughs)
- And stuff, Nicholas Cage things happen.
And then the world literally ends.
'Cause I think it's a solar
flare that kills everyone.
Spoilers if you ever
wanted to watch "Knowing."
- I wanted to watch "Knowing."
- If you ever wanted to
watch the masterpiece
that is Nicholas Cage's "Knowing."
(everyone laughs)
How did we get on this topic?
- Just talking about movies.
Talking about horror movies.
That was a horror.
- Is that a horror movie?
- I think it is horror.
Supposed to be horror.
- As in it's horrible.
- I'm looking it up right now.
Hey!
I'm looking it up right now.
"Knowing" Nicholas Cage.
- Can we take a break?
'Cause I need to pee.
And I'm very hot right now.
- Yeah, I find out it is
a science fiction film,
not a horror film.
But it was-
- It was pretty horror.
- It felt like horror.
- Whatever happened to Nicholas Cage?
- I don't know, he's just busy.
- Kind of went off the rails, didn't he?
- A little bit.
I don't know.
I don't feel educated
enough to talk about him.
(Connor laughs)
I don't really keep up
with Nicholas Cage's life.
- I mean, how many Nicholas
Cage films have you seen?
- A fair amount.
- Too many.
- Really?
- Probably more than I care to admit.
- I probably watched one and I was like-
- What?
- One?
- You didn't watch "Con Air?"
- Yeah, "Con Air," I was
about to say "Con Air."
- I've heard of that one.
- Fucking classic.
- I think I watched,
what was the one where he was in Vegas?
- "Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas."
- Yeah, "Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas."
I watched that.
- The film with Las Vegas in the title.
- Did that have Nicholas Cage in it?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
that was Nicholas Cage.
- Oh, had no idea.
- I watched "Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas,"
and I was like, all right.
- Wait, is that a remake?
Is it a remake?
I feel like it is.
- I think it is.
Yeah, yeah.
I watched that and I
saw his like, you know,
the scene where he like
fucking loses it in the casino?
- Oh yeah!
That one!
- And I was like, all right.
I just got like, at
that moment I was like,
I understand Nicholas Cage now.
And then everything else I've
seen from Nicholas Cage has
just been like YouTube clips
from other movies that he's in.
- Honestly, that's all you need
to like experience Nicholas Cage.
- I feel like that is the best way
to experience Nicholas Cage
is out of context movie clips.
- I think one of my favorite
YouTube Nicholas Cage clips is,
there's a lot by the way.
There's a lot.
But one of my favorites
is just someone edited him
like during like a driving
scene or something,
and it's just like,
it's just him like getting into a car,
and just, it out of context,
it looks like he's just play driving.
Like, it's so hard to describe,
but it's, you gotta watch it.
And another thing is just Nicholas Cage
slowly losing his mind as well.
Have you seen that one?
Where it's just like him slowly
getting more and more crazy
as the clip goes to the
soundtrack of Requiem of Dreams.
(everyone laughs)
It's absolutely fucking amazing.
- I don't think I've seen this one.
- I got to show you afterwards.
- [Navi] "Fear and
Loathing" is not a remake.
- Oh, it's not a remake?
- [Navi] It's a screenplay
adaptation of a novel, I think.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- It's not a remake.
- But yeah, what happened
to Nicholas Cage?
We could use more Nicholas
Cage films honestly.
(everyone laughs)
I don't know.
I can't remember how we got
onto the topic of Nicholas Cage.
- Oh no, I lied.
I've seen that other
film with Nicholas Cage.
The, not the bees one.
What the fuck was that called again?
(everyone laughs)
What the fuck is the name of that movie?
- I have not seen the bees one.
- I've not seen that movie, but I've seen-
- I've seen the clips.
- "Wicker Man."
I saw that.
I watched "Wicker Man" just
because that, you know,
the fucking "not the bees!" one was like,
it was a meme for the longest time.
So I'm like, well, I mean.
It was a funny meme,
but I kind of want to see
this scene in context.
I just got really curious.
I was like, I want to see-
- Do you need to see the scene in context?
- So, I watched it in context.
- Oh, did you?
- Yeah, makes just as much
sense out of context honestly.
It was the first time where I watched it
and then I instantly recognized the meme.
I was like, oh, this is the scene.
Finally, I'll be able to
understand why they pour the bees
in the basket.
And I watched it, I was like,
nope, I don't know.
Did I like pass out for like
five minutes or something.
It just suddenly went to the scene.
I was like, wait, I don't understand why,
this is kind of unnecessary.
(everyone laughs)
- What's that film even about?
- I don't even remember.
The only scene I remember
is the bee scene.
I think everybody who watched "Wicker Man"
only remembers that scene.
- The bees scene.
- Is there any other scene in the movie?
It's just that.
- Nothing that's notable, no.
Nothing that's worth putting to memory.
- My God.
- Yeah, like on the topic of horror films,
one thing that always like
fascinated me as a kid
that I don't think is
around anymore is, like,
I feel like part of the, you know,
the blockbuster or rental DVD experience
for me was going to the
rental, like the Blockbuster
and just seeing like the
fucking horrific DVD covers
of like every horror movie.
I don't know why.
Like, those fascinated me as a kid.
- Were they bad?
Or like, what do you mean horrific?
Like, scary?
- Yeah, they were like
really fucking terrifying.
- I was like, 'cause the
Blockbuster near my house,
well, that's not there anymore obviously.
It was separated into
aisles for different genres.
All of the action blockbusters
were in one aisle,
all the romance were in one aisle.
And then right on like the
far left of the Blockbuster
there was the aisle for
all the horror films.
I was so scared to walk down that aisle.
(everyone laughs)
Just because, like, just in my periphery,
you just see this like
terrifying looking movies.
And it's, like, usually it's
got like a really scary face
that's like looking right in front.
I'm just like-
- You were scared of seeing the horror?
- Honestly, I'm like, I'm
kind of a pussy honestly.
When it comes to films,
I'm kind of a pussy.
- I'm a proud pussy.
- I will happily admit that, like,
Sydney tries to get me
to watch horror film.
I'm like, no, Sydney, I am too scared.
- I think 'cause I had an older
brother, two older brothers,
I think I just saw the
covers laying around a bunch.
'Cause they were like, you know,
my oldest brother was like,
I don't know.
I actually don't know how many
years older he is than me.
I can't keep track.
- I can actually remember that-
- Like five or six.
- I can actually remember the time
where I realized I hated
horror films is because. like,
I think I was like five or six years old.
And I was in the living room
and my parents were watching "The Ring."
- Oh.
- And like, obviously, you know,
I was kind of just hanging around
while they were just watching that movie.
But I remember I looked over
at the TV and it was the scene
where comes out of the TV.
And that was the moment where
I was like, I hate this.
I hate this.
I hate anything that is like this.
I hate any film that
is like blue gradient.
(everyone laughs)
- Blue gradient!
The VHS.
- The true horror is
when you're like 14 watching
a film with your parents
and a sex scene comes on.
- Oh my God.
- #Relatable.
- And you're like, I
don't know what this is.
I have no idea what's going on.
- Even a kiss scene for me was like-
- Really?
You're like.
- Like, a way too dragged out kiss scene.
You know what I mean?
It's not like a peck.
It's like a make-out scene.
It doesn't go to the sex scene.
It's just stopped.
It's probably like a PG film or something.
It's just a really long make-out scene.
I'm just like, guys, we get it.
Get a fucking room.
All right, please.
My parents are here.
Stop it.
- 'Cause like I remember back way back
when the age of like teen comedy flicks
with stuff like "American
Pie" and stuff like that.
I don't know why-
- "American Pie" was
always on TV in the UK.
- Really?
- On ITV2.
It was always on.
- Yeah, it was always on.
- It was always on at like 10:00 to 11:00.
For some reason they play
all the "American Pie" films
all the time.
Like, everyone in the UK
has seen "American Pie."
- It was always uncut as well.
It was the closest thing we had like to-
- They showed boobs and stuff.
And I was like, whoa, whoa, it's 11:00 PM.
(everyone laughs)
- And of course your parents
would have to walk in
during every fucking nude scene,
every fucking make-out scene.
'Cause I remember my parents walked in
when I was watching "American Pie 2,"
and of course there was like
the lesbian make-out scene.
And of course that was the scene
that they had to walk through.
(everyone laughs)
- Have those movies aged well?
I don't think they've aged-
- I don't think they've aged well at all.
- Yeah, I haven't seen
"American Pie" in a while.
- I think all those kinds of, like,
teenage comedy films
have just not aged well.
Like, "Scary Movie" has not aged well.
- "Scary Movie" was never funny.
- It's less funny now.
- One time I was watching
something and it was, like,
I think there was drugs and sex in it
and I was just playing my GameBoy.
- Yeah.
- While this was going on.
They were like, oh,
I remember I was like 12 or something,
my parents were like, "Oh, don't worry.
"He doesn't understand anything."
And I'm like, I'm like, I think I do.
I'm just pretending like
I'm not paying attention.
(everyone laughs)
They were like, "I think it's fine.
"I don't think he gets it.
"I don't think he understands
what's happening."
And I'm like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah."
- Meanwhile you're like, "Damn."
- I'm like, "Whoa, this is weird."
- Did your parents ever say anything
during like those fucking awkward scenes
or was it just like the awkward silence.
- It was just silent.
That would make it awkward.
- I always used to like
get up and be like,
"I gotta go to the bathroom."
(everyone laughs)
- Did you actually?
- Yeah, I did.
- If one of my parents didn't do it,
I was like, "All right,
"I'll be the one to go
to the bathroom then."
- You know what film I remember
watching at like age 10
with my parents?
I think this is why they played it
'cause I was so young where they thought,
he's not gonna understand anything,
was "Brokeback Mountain."
- Nice.
- You'd like my parents.
- Okay.
- I don't remember what happened in it
'cause I was 10.
But I do remember there
was gay things happening.
- It's just Jake Gyllenhaal
and Heath Ledger having
a lot of sex.
- I remember.
But that's yeah, I was like, oh, okay.
I don't understand what's happening.
But my parents were like, for
some reason they were like,
"Yeah, let's watch Brokeback
Mountain with our son."
- It's so unfortunate though
because that's actually a
really fucking good movie.
- No, 'cause I went back and
watched it after I was like,
I think 18 'cause I had
watched "The Dark Knight,"
and I was like, "Whoa, this
Heath Ledger guy can act good."
(everyone laughs)
And then obviously 'cause I
found out about his death.
Well, I got to watch everything he's in.
And I was like, "Wow, this is good.
"I think I remember watching this."
But I couldn't remember when.
And I was like, oh.
- The PTSD kicked in.
- Like, flashback.
I remember now.
But I remember I was
speaking to my friend,
and he was like, "Yeah, do
you ever just feel awkward
"when sex scenes come on when
you're with your friends."
And I'm like, no.
I'm like, no, not at all.
- When you're with your
friends, it's different.
- Why would I feel awkward
with a sex scene with my mates?
It's just weird, isn't it?
And I'm like, no.
- I don't think I've ever
watched a sex scene with my mates
now that I think about it.
(everyone laughs)
- Is that like a thing
you have to check off?
- I don't know.
- You never watched a
film with your friends
that has a sex scene in it?
- I'm trying to think.
- I think I've watched
like funny porno plots
with my friends.
Like, fake taxi with my friends.
- I've just watched porn with my friends.
(everyone laughs)
- I think I have watched,
I've been like, "Let's watch
this funny porno," you know?
- Yeah, of course.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I don't think I've ever
gone through that, no.
- That's like my favorite pastime is
like watching cursed porn with my friends.
(everyone laughs)
- I had a friend as well who was like,
he can watch normal movies
with straight sex in it,
but he couldn't watch normal movies
with gay sex scenes in it with his friends
'cause he was like just
super uncomfortable.
- That's just a bit of macho insecurity.
- Yeah.
- That sounds a bit insecure to me.
- I was like, "I don't know, man.
"This all sounds like
you're a little insecure."
He's like, "No, no, no, no.
"I just don't like it."
I'm like, "Why don't you like it?"
And then he was like,
"I'm not homophobic."
I'm like, oh, I don't know.
- "I'm not homophobic, but..."
- What's wrong with a
little guy on guy action?
I'm like, frankly, as a man,
I enjoy watching other dudes.
(everyone laughs)
I think there's nothing manlier
than being able to sit there
and enjoy that, you know, come on, man.
What's wrong?
- Just blokes hanging out, isn't it?
- He's like lads, lads?
- I feel like, yeah,
a lot of guys are like that
in the UK though, you know?
- There's always one guy like that
I feel in every guy group.
- I feel like lads culture
is definitely like a thing
in the UK, which is like kind of-
- Same in Australia, yeah.
- Yeah, do you guys have
lads culture in Australia?
- Do you have friends who
would be like that if you try-
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
You know, like, 'cause I went
to a boys school as well,
so it was even more so where it's like
just macho insecurity everywhere
where it's like, you know,
you'd be out after school.
- It's kinda toxic.
- Yeah, you'd be out after
school and there'd just be
like a girl from like
a nearby girls school.
"You should totally smash her, bro.
"You should totally smash her."
And I'm just like, I'm not-
- You know, I try not
to be confrontational
because they're your
friends, but I also try and,
I'm not gonna sit there and be like,
"Dude, that's pretty, you
know, that's pretty not okay."
- This is pretty fucked.
- I've had arguments with
my friends about it as well
where I'll just be like, "Yeah,
that's kind of homophobic."
I don't know if you realize
it is, but that is homophobic.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Do you think because we spend
so much time on the internet
that we've just had like more awareness
about this kind of culture and stuff?
- I think so because, you know,
a lot of my friends would never be like,
I don't think they would ever be like,
"I hate gay people" or anything like that.
But also you have to understand
where that comes from
if there's something where you
can watch a normal sex scene,
but you can't watch a gay sex scene.
Like, why is that?
Like, what's going on there?
Like, if you're a normal person surely
who doesn't give a fuck,
you'd have no problem to either, right?
Maybe you would find one
hotter than the other,
but surely you wouldn't have a problem.
I don't know if this is too
much for "Trash Taste" viewers.
- I mean, like, just because you're okay
with watching a sex scene doesn't
mean you need to be, like,
into it.
- No, that's what I mean.
That's what I'm saying.
- There's a difference
between being into it
and just watching it.
- That's what I was saying.
That's what I was trying to be like.
I was like, yeah, you don't
have to actively dislike it,
but like you don't have
to like turn it off
or like go into the other room.
You know what I mean?
Like, you can just sit there and be like,
all right, it's not for me,
but I'm not gonna be disgusted by it.
- It's part of the story.
It's like, whatever.
- Yeah, that's what I was saying.
I was like, you know, if
it's part of the plot,
it's what it is, man.
Like, they're like, "Oh, I don't know.
"It's just kinda weird, isn't it?"
I'm like, "Is it weird?
"Explain how it's weird."
- Don't watch "Brokeback
Mountain" if that's the case.
(everyone laughs)
That's literally what that movie's about.
- I was like, "That's the problem though.
"You think it's weird."
Like it's not like, it's
not weird that people fuck!
- I think the problem is that
it's just a lot of the times,
especially like in lads culture,
people just have never
thought about this too deeply.
'Cause that's-
- They have these,
yeah, I'm not saying
that someone is, yeah.
I totally agree.
Go ahead.
- Yeah, no, 'cause like
this is what I feel
every time I go back to my hometown
and I see some of, like, my
hometown friends who like,
I very much grew up in like lads culture,
hanging out with like lads, lads, lads.
And they still like fucking go to,
every fucking summer go to Ibiza
and try to smash as
many birds as possible.
- That's what it is.
- That kind of like lads culture.
And I'm just like,
as I've grown older, I'm just like,
oh this is a kind of a toxic
mindset in a lot of ways.
You know, it's very much...
'Cause I think the problem is
that they don't really talk about it.
They don't really talk
about their feelings
or like really think
about things too deeply
because that's not a lads thing to do.
- That's considered weak.
- Yeah, that's considered weak.
You're not an alpha male
if you talk about your feelings and shit.
- And also, you know,
they don't really have
conversations like this.
- Yeah, they don't.
- So normally when it's been
something I've spoken about
with people it's, like,
especially in like where I'm from,
it's not the first person
who's ever been like,
"Now why do you feel that way about this?"
(everyone laughs)
"Now why is it that it
makes you uncomfortable?"
You know what I mean?
- So, what do you mean by that?
It's just like.
- And I've had like
confrontations about it
'cause it's, like, they
get very defensive about it
'cause they feel like, "Oh, shit, wait.
"Is he trying to say that I'm in the wrong
"for feeling this way?"
And it's like, well,
no, I'm not trying to.
But it's, like, why are
you feeling that way?
Maybe just think about it.
- Just want to have a discussion about it.
- Maybe look at what's going on there.
- It's funny because, like,
some of the most kind of
insecure people I've ever met are
like, some of the like
biggest lads I've ever seen.
Like, the proper like gym bros who...
- Sometimes it's insecurity.
Sometimes it's toxic masculinity.
Sometimes it's homophobia.
It's, like, whatever it is,
it's like get to the core of it.
That's what's bothering you.
You can't watch "Brokeback Mountain"
without being disgusted.
- It's a great movie.
- All I'm saying is if you're
a guy don't be afraid to talk
about your feelings with other guys.
I feel like I didn't have
that when I was growing up
because I thought that
it was the mentality
where if I did this with my
bros, that I was the weak one.
You know, that's not what
bros do to each other.
- Yeah, you know, I
wouldn't say we're like SJW
or anything like that.
I just, I don't know.
I just don't want to discriminate.
Why should you, you know?
Just my personal opinion.
I'm sure that,
I'm no doubt there's some
viewers of "Trash Taste"
being like, "I can't
believe they've spoken
"about this issue," and stuff, but I mean-
- It's a sensitive topic.
- Stuff that I would talk about,
I mean, there's some
things that are sensitive
and there's some things where I'm like,
no, that's just straight up wrong.
- Of course, of course, yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, there's some
things where I'm just like,
I think we should talk about this,
and I think it's, you know,
I think it's not toxic at all
to at least start a conversation
because I think a lot of the times,
a lot of people just haven't really,
never really put any thought into it.
- A lot of time they don't.
- Yeah, they grew up in a culture,
they grew up in a lifestyle,
and that has just never
put them in a position
that challenges the way they think.
- And if someone does feel
uncomfortable with us talking
about this topic or hearing that idea
that makes you uncomfortable,
I would say just like,
don't get angry about it.
Don't react to it.
Just think like-
- Just turn off "Trash Taste," go watch
"Brokeback Mountain" maybe.
- No, no, no.
Just think, why does it, like,
why does it get you angry?
Like, what about it?
If that's like a whole religious thing.
All right, fine.
That's your problem with that.
Like, I don't know.
- Yeah, 'cause, like, I just
feel like it's better now
for at least people who are,
like, I guess on the internet
and especially on social media
'cause people are talking
about this more often,
which is good, but I still like, there,
you forget sometimes that we are not,
I don't even know if we're
the majority, you know,
because every time I go home-
- I don't know.
Most people don't talk about it.
- It's hard to tell.
I'm like so ingrained in,
obviously our jobs are
surrounded with the internet,
and surrounded with
people who think like me,
that it's weird whenever you go to like,
go back home, see family,
see friends from back home,
And you're just like, wow,
everyone thinks exactly the same.
Everyone has not changed much at all
because they just there's
no one in the community
or in this group of friends
that are exposed to the
same thing as we are.
- No, totally.
'Cause obviously on my
channel I'm very pro LGBTQ,
but like obviously going back home,
it's not a thing that's spoken about much.
It is kind of.
It depends who you ask really.
- I think now more than
before, definitely,
with how the world's just changing.
- My parents are pretty good with it.
I always try to educate
them as well when I can.
Try and tell them about it.
- I would like to think most of the time
it is just pure ignorance and-
- Oh, totally.
Especially in small towns.
You know, obviously not everyone is
on the internet all the time
and everyone's in a big city,
you're surrounded by it,
so it's, you know, a lot of the time they
just don't come across it.
They're just like, "Oh,
that guy's very funny on TV
"and he's gay.
"Oh, really?"
That's what it's like.
That's what parents are like.
They're like, "You know, he's gay?"
- Cool.
- That's like a thing, you know?
But I mean, you know, it's,
I mean, it's everywhere now.
I don't know.
It sucks that it's one of those things
that it even has to be somewhat
controversial to talk about.
And we haven't really spoke
about it on "Trash Taste"
so I'm sure that some people
will be alienated by it,
but it sucks that even has to be something
that alienates people.
It's just a fact.
People are gay.
Get over it.
- We just like "Brokeback Mountain," man.
What can I say?
- It's a great film!
- It's a fucking awesome movie.
(everyone laughs)
- Trash Taste Brokeback
Mountain watch along.
- Heath Ledger, Jake
Gyllenhaal, fucking amazing job.
- Yeah.
You sometimes forget Heath
Ledger's a fucking Australian
in that movie.
- Is he Australian?
- Yeah, he's an Aussie.
- Did you think he's British?
A lot of people think he's British.
- I have no idea.
- I think everyone thinks he's American.
- Oh, do they?
- Yeah, I thought he was American
because my first experience
with Heath Ledger was
"10 Things You Hate About Me."
- Wait, Heath Ledger is Australian?
- Heath Ledger is Australian.
- What?
- I didn't know that.
- Jake Gyllenhaal is American obviously.
- I thought you meant Jake Gyllenhaal.
- No, no, no.
Jake Gyllenhaal is American.
Heath Ledger is,
the Joker is Australian.
Just great actor.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
Yeah, I feel like a lot of, you know,
if you're in Hollywood,
I think we've talked
about this, haven't we?
How they're good at, like,
they're good at doing the American accent.
But you watch like some
of like the worst attempts
of people attempting a British accent,
it's comically bad.
- I love Keanu Reeves.
His British accent.
- Oh, him in like "Dracula."
- So bad.
(everyone laughs)
- That was hilarious.
- It's a tie between that and fucking,
at the end of "Django"
when Tarantino appears,
and it's like in Australian.
- "What's goin' on, mates?
"What's goin' on?"
- I died on the inside when I saw that.
I was like, this movie was almost perfect
and then Tarantino-
- "Bollock!"
(everyone laughs)
- I'm like, I'm glad
he blew up at the end.
Someone needed to get rid of that.
(everyone laughs)
- I'm sitting here like what
do we title this episode?
- Yeah, right?
- What have we even spoken about today?
- I don't know.
- How did we even get onto this?
Oh, the summer is hot.
The summer is hot.
- Summer block.
"Trash Taste Summer Blockbuster."
- Fuck no.
Fuck no.
- I love how like during
the conversation earlier
about whatever the fuck it was just,
I was trying to listen
to what you were saying,
but just from the outside,
I could just hear like
a shit load of cicadas.
- Cicadas?
- Yeah.
- Cicada.
I say cicada.
- Cicadas?
- Isn't it cicadas?
- Cicadas.
- Am I the weird one?
I say cicada.
- It's cicada.
- Okay, Google, how do
you pronounce cicada?
Sorry to anyone who,
fucking I probably just like-
- We can't continue with the
podcast 'til we find this out?
What does it say?
- Cicada king, rise up.
- Cicada.
- It is cicada.
- I don't even know.
- [Meilyne] Cicada.
- Yeah!
- Fuck off!
- Hell yeah!
- Wait, what, what-
- What site are you using?
- Does that say American or UK?
What is it?
- [Meilyne] Oh, America is cicada.
- Oh, I say cicada.
- Wait, are you kidding me?
- I'm correct!
- British say cicada and
Americans say cicada?
- [Navi] This is American so.
- [Joey] And the British say cicada.
- [Connor] Well, the thing
is that we don't have them
in the UK.
- My life is a lie.
My life is a fucking lie.
- You know, cicada's been one of those,
oh, I should say cicada now.
Cicada is one of those words
that I've only heard Americans say
'cause we don't have it in the UK.
No one says it in the UK.
- True, true.
- I've never heard any British person say-
- It literally sounds like
something out of "Harry Potter."
No, it's cicada.
Cicada.
- Have you heard a
British person say cicada?
- No, I have never heard a
British person say cicada.
- I'm saying cicada now.
I'm getting it in my head now.
- You have to rewire your brain now.
- I remember 'cause we literally,
we literally had a Netflix shoot
where we had to talk about
like summer anime things.
I thought cicada or cicada was spelled
C-I-R-C-A-D-A.
- He literally wrote circada.
- Circada.
(everyone laughs)
I did circada.
Yeah, I thought cicada had
an R in it this entire time
and apparently it doesn't.
- It's circada now.
- Yeah, but, yeah I mean...
I've said this before, the Netflix shoot.
But I remember when I
first moved to Japan,
and I literally had gone
my entire life thinking
that every cicada sound
effect in every anime was
just a stock sound effect.
'Cause they all sound exactly the same.
You watch like one summer anime episode,
and you're like,
they're just using the
same fucking sound effect
as the other anime.
And I didn't realize
until I moved to Japan
that cicadas just all sound
exactly the fucking same.
I thought it was
just a fucking audio
jungle stock sound effect.
No.
I don't know how they sound so similar.
- It's literally just been
hardwired into their brain
to be like, sound like this
at this exact interval.
- Yeah, to the point
where I was like sitting
at home one night or one day,
and I literally thought I had the TV on
playing a random anime.
I didn't realize that
just the window was open.
I literally like went to my
living room to turn off the TV
because I was like, no
one's watching anything.
And lo and behold, it was just the window.
And I couldn't tell the difference
between a TV stock sound
effect and the real life.
- Man, have you seen them flying?
- Yeah.
- They're fucking massive.
- They're terrifying.
- I was outside the "Trash Taste" office
and I was just walking,
listening to music, just jamming,
and one flew in my fucking face.
I fucking smacked it.
I smacked it, and I felt really bad
'cause it hit the woman in front of me.
(everyone laughs)
On her back.
- You literally just
tossed a cicada at her.
- And she turned around, and I was like...
- Fucking playing ping pong with a cicada.
- I just hit it 'cause I panicked.
I fucking smacked it.
- No, what's scarier is when
they land on your balcony.
But you think they're dead.
- They just don't move, yeah.
- They just like kind of
bump and just flop down.
You're like, oh, is he dead?
And then you touch it
and it's like (yells)
- Yeah, there was one outside my door,
so I opened the door and
it and I like (yells)
"What is that?"
- Scarier than any horror film.
- 'Cause I just opened my door.
You don't expect them.
There's nothing in my door.
You never expect a jump
scare at your door.
(Joey laughs)
That's fucked up!
- I'm gonna use the last of
my life to troll this human.
- It was literally like under the door.
So, I opened the door and it was just,
it got like, the door
rubbed it or something
and you here like (crunches)
And I was like (yells) what is that?
I'd never seen one before either.
This is my first time seeing one.
- I had never seen one before either.
So, I had no idea what they look like.
And these fucking shit heads are so big.
They're fucking massive.
- I just fucking yeeted
back in my apartment.
I was like (yells)
- They're terrifying.
- And also another thing I
didn't know is that, like,
I had always assumed,
like, I remember the first
time I came to Japan,
like these motherfuckers are loud.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- Like, you need to wear,
you need like noise canceling headphones
to like even survive outside.
- You think it's like a swarm
of them, but it's just one.
- I walked past this tree
and I'm like, man, these,
there are like a swarm of
cicadas just in this tree.
And then it, like, it just
like suddenly just stops
and I'm like, what's going on?
And then I realized
it's one motherfucker
making all this sound.
One motherfucker makes so, it's so loud.
And it's actually like impressive
how fucking loud the cicada is.
Because, like, I'm on my balcony
and, like, I can hear what I
think is a swarm of cicadas
on like the other side
of the city or something.
And then I realize it's just one,
because it just like, it's
so weird, like having like a,
it's so weird going outside
and just hearing like a fucking noise.
Like, it sounds like an alarm.
And then it just suddenly stops as well.
And then it just suddenly stops.
- Why do they make noise?
What are they trying to,
to mate or something?
- Yeah, it's a mating call.
- Fuck's sake.
Why are they so fucking loud?
- Don't they like rub their
legs together to make that sound
or something?
- Like, a violin?
- Yeah, like the world's shittiest violin.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, 'cause apparently
they can only mate
during like a very short
period of their life.
- During the summer.
- Yeah, during the summer.
So they're like fucking
horny as fuck, man.
They need to fuck.
- They're the lads of the insect world.
- And then they fuck once and they die.
And then that's it.
That's just their entire life.
They live for that one
fuck, and then they die.
- They make as much noise as
possible to get that one fuck.
- "Sorry, I came to early," dies.
(everyone laughs)
- Imagine nutting and
then immediately dying.
- Honestly-
- The best way to go.
- Sometimes I've nutted and
I wanted to die right after,
you know what I mean?
- Honestly, I can think
of worse ways to die
than having like a nut so
amazing that you're like,
"All right, life is peach now."
(everyone laughs)
Death initiate.
- Some people die from cows.
- For fuck sake!
- I'm bringing this back
because after that I realized,
Garnt was like, "How do
people die from cows?"
I'm like, "Garnt, they're like four tons.
'What do you mean, how
do people die from cows?"
- So many people in the
suburbs reminding Garnt.
- You can die from cows, Garnt!
- You can die from anything
that's like four fucking tons,
from any like heavy animal.
- That's why.
So don't make me look like an idiot
for saying a cow can kill you.
A cow can fucking kill you.
- Just because a cow can
kill you doesn't mean that,
you know, probably if
you get killed by a cow,
you're doing something stupid.
That's just my opinion.
You'd have to try really
fucking hard to die from a cow.
- Most ways people die are
from stupid ways, Garnt.
Believe it or not.
- I remember I saw a statistic in Japan
where it's like more people in Japan die
from vending machines than
they do shark attacks.
- Well, that makes sense, yeah.
- Wait, how?
- From shaking the vending machine
and it landing on you and dying.
- Okay, well that's just
idiots being idiots.
- You deserve that if you're
shaking a vending machine.
- That's what I mean.
It's the same thing with a cow.
You're not gonna be walking
through the fucking paddock
and then suddenly a cow's like,
"Let me come and squish you!"
(everyone laughs)
- I think they can bite you as well.
- Oh yeah.
They kick you as well.
- Also, if you're strong enough
to push a vending machine
on yourself, why are you
wasting all that talent?
You know what I mean?
Like, how do you get the
vending machine to fall on you?
It can't be easy.
Do you jump on it?
Like, how are people doing this?
- I don't know.
- You cannot.
Have you tried moving a vending machine?
It is not easy.
Like, you really have to be
committed to the stupid act.
You really are admitting like,
all right, I'm breaking a sweat today.
- This is how I'm gonna go.
- Taking off the Yeezys for this one.
- That's what I'm saying about
dying from cows, you know?
Why fucking try, like, lying under a cow
or just like standing behind a cow.
Just go swim in shark
infested waters apparently!
- You know, I think you've
more chance of dying
via the cow honestly.
Have you not seen enough LiveLink videos
of people fucking with animals to realize?
- Do you just casually sit
down and watch LiveLink.
I think I'd rather watch a horror film.
- Sometimes you're on Facebook or Twitter,
and one gets on there somehow and-
- How?
- I don't know, it just happens.
- On Twitter?
- Yeah.
You just see like a, you know,
like a monkey punching a man or something.
I don't know.
(Garnt laughs)
- Wait, what?
- What accounts are you following?
- Justin.
- True, he does retweet some of those.
- You just see shit,
and then like, people like
fucking around with monkeys
and then the monkey just beats them up.
- Honestly, like if I
see the LiveLink logo,
that's like a, I should probably not-
- There is a worrying amount
of people who think that like,
they can just like do whatever
they want near animals.
- Yeah.
- But it's normally, like,
third world countries.
And it's, like, scary.
'Cause they're like
fucking with like a monkey
and then the monkey just beats them up,
and you're like, well,
I mean, fair enough.
- I mean, what did you expect?
- Kinda had the right.
Innocent, yeah.
- You're literally fucking
with the smartest animal.
- Yeah, 'cause like I'm just very wary
whenever I see anything LiveLink
because I've seen enough
fucked up shit on the internet.
- LiveLink is also a meme.
I've seen people put
LiveLink on like the meme.
So, now I'm like, I'm not
sure if it's a meme or not.
- It's like playing a game of
like Reddit 50/50 or whatever.
- That's the only time I've
seen enough LiveLink to know
where I'm just like, no.
Nothing good comes out of LiveLink.
- Sometimes it comes on and you're like,
this is intriguing enough
where I don't think I
can stop watching now.
The premise, I'm hooked.
- I don't know, man.
I quickly pull the plug.
- You have more willpower than me.
- This ain't worth it.
- When I see the premise
for the first one second of the video,
I'm like, "Damn, I can't turn it off now."
(everyone laughs)
Is that wrong of me?
I feel like that's bad.
I mean, I'm just wired to clickbait.
I don't know.
- Yeah, monkey brain activates.
- Your curiosity gets the best of you.
- Speaking about you
spelling cicada incorrectly.
- Circada.
- I realized like the other day,
I'm like, shit, I can't spell shit
without autocorrect anymore.
- What?
- My spelling is so bad
without autocorrect.
- Yeah, that's pretty much me as well.
- I realized now when it's not on,
I just kind of like type shit
and I know that it will fix it for me.
- That's a bad habit.
- I just type fast.
- Yeah, I mean, I got
something similar as well
where I'm like, I can't do
mental arithmetic anymore.
Like, I literally like,
like, I'm just like, oh,
what's nine times eight?
And I'm just like, let me
get out the calculator.
(everyone laughs)
I'm so reliant on-
- I can do it, but it'll
take me like 20 Seconds.
- I can do it, but it
requires thinking and I don't,
I'm not all about that, man.
- Nine times eight?
- Yeah, that's easy though.
- I was gonna say.
- Think about it, Garnt.
- Wait...
(everyone laughs)
72.
- There you go.
- I had to think about it!
- Well, done for graduating middle school.
- Masters in engineering by the way.
- What was your method of getting that?
- I don't...
- 'Cause the nine times
tables is the easiest.
- Yeah, that's what I would've done.
I would have the nine times nine is 81
then just minus eight.
- Oh, that's way too complicated.
- There's an even easier way.
Anything times nine is super fucking easy.
- No, I mean, I don't
really have a system.
It's just figuring it out.
- It's whatever your brain
is wired to do fast, right?
- Yeah, well, for me, if
it's nine times eight,
then it's, like, well eight.
So, it starts with a seven
because whatever your timesing by nine is
always one digit below.
And then the two digits sums up to nine.
Seven plus two is nine.
- You know how every
time you would ever have
like a new math teacher,
they would always teach you
that weird way of solving
a plus and a minus?
You know what I mean?
They were like, "Right, so
we're gonna add 425 to 522."
And then they're gonna do,
"Right, so we're gonna add
the four to the five, easy."
And I'm like, do we really
need to write this down?
Can we just like, can we just...
- And then there's always like
just the really obscure ways
to do it as well
where it's like there's
got to be an easier way.
- Yeah.
- It's like, "All right, so
when you bring the one over,
"pull out your dictionary."
(everyone laughs)
- Or it would ne like dividing by.
And they would have
this weird ass timetable
or something to do it.
And I'm like, this feels so convoluted.
Why not just like figure
out some other method.
- It's like, teacher when am
I ever gonna divide 973 by 67?
Like, I'm never going to.
- I'm never gonna go and count down.
I didn't need to know this shit.
(everyone laughs)
- Every single, like,
yeah, it is great that you,
if you can do that with your mind,
but there's-
- Great party trick.
- There's absolutely no setting
where you are ever not
gonna be using a calculator.
And even if you are,
they will not allow you to do that
because they won't trust you.
You should be using a
calculator for good practice.
You know what I mean?
- Even if you could divide insane numbers,
people would be like, "No, that's not it."
- It's good for like estimates
when you're talking engineering terms.
You're like, "Okay, well,
can we maybe try this much?
"No, I don't think, just
off the top of my head,
"that doesn't seem right."
That's good.
But in general, like, you
know, there's exams, you know-
- It's just funny how
like mental arithmetic has
just become kind of like a party trick.
There's always like, you
always see that one guy
every so often where you get like the bill
and they can just like divide
exactly the right amount
in their head before-
- But it's also like the
shittiest type of party trick
because it's the party trick that you do
and nobody believes you.
(everyone laughs)
- People would check it anyway, right?
- It's like, "Nah, let me
pull the calculator out."
(everyone laughs)
"Oh, it is right, wow, very good."
- Five times five is 25.
- No.
- Bullshit, let me check that.
- I just work via round numbers now.
That is just my life.
But yes, exactly the same as spelling now
where I just, I could not
live without autocorrect.
And I don't know.
I feel like it's-
- Do you have those words that you just,
you know what they look
like, but you're like,
I just can't be bothered to
learn how to spell it right.
- How do you spell necessary?
- I was literally about to say that.
(Garnt laughs)
That is the one where I'm like,
I honestly cannot remember,
is it two Cs, two Ss?
- Two Ss, right?
- I don't know.
I'm pretty sure it's-
- The one for me that always fucks me up
that I still never get
right is guaranteed.
- Yeah.
- I'm like is the U in there?
Is there an A in this?
Is it gwaranteed or is garanteed?
- This is why, I don't care.
I haven't like...
Yeah, necessarily.
I'm just like, I'm
pretty sure it's two Ss.
No, it's not, is it?
- It's two Ss.
- I don't know, maybe it is.
- Yeah, N-E-C-E-S-S-A-R-Y, right?
- [Connor] Yeah, I'm pretty sure it is.
- Hold on, let me check.
(everyone laughs)
- Let me get out the autocorrect.
- I just type and then
click, yeah, it's that one.
- Yeah.
- But the thing about
spelling is that it doesn't,
at the end of the day-
- Spelling is irrelevant.
(everyone laughs)
- At the end of the day, you know,
you can spell a word wrong
and people will still get
like the meaning of the word
most of the time.
Isn't there-
- Like phonetics.
- Yeah, I mean, haven't
you seen like the video
where if you put the first letter right
and the last letter
right, and just mix it up.
- Everyone on the internet has seen that.
Have you seen the ballerina
that spins the other way too, Garnt?
- Have you seen the dress
that's blue and gold?
- Oh yeah.
I remember that.
Oh my God.
I completely forgot about that.
- The internet was on fire
for a week unnecessarily
over a fucking dress.
- I remember meme culture.
I remember when that was the
hot thing back in the day.
- I knew that dress meme went
too far when people were like,
"All right, so I went into Photoshop
"and I got the color draw,
"and I can confirm the hex digits
"that it is in fact blue and gold."
- Wasn't there that like audio kind of-
- Yanny and Laurel.
- Yeah, that one.
- Oh yeah!
I remember that.
- I just saw that, I was like, who cares?
- Yeah, I felt like after
the whole dress debacle,
it felt like everyone was
looking for the next thing
to interpret differently.
And I just didn't give a fuck.
- That was a nice meme
that lasted three days.
- Yeah, I remember like the
only, what would they call it?
The audio...
I'm like-
- Audio illusion.
- Audio illusion!
That's it.
Actually, it's not
really an audio illusion.
It's just, did you ever,
did you guys ever do
like the frequency test
where you have to like
test your frequency?
And, like, I remember I was,
I remember my frequency was
like so fucking good as a kid.
And I thought I'm never gonna lose this.
I don't know.
Like, as a kid, did
you ever get that point
where a grown up told you that
this is gonna happen to you
when you grow up,
and as a kid, you're just like,
that's never gonna happen to me.
That's never gonna fucking happen to me.
I remember the first time I felt old
was the first time I did,
the second time I did a frequency test
when I was like mid 20s,
and I'm just like, this
isn't the same number
as I remember as a kid!
The grown ups were right, I'm getting old!
- Wait, so is the frequency test
like the how much you can hear?
Is that the one?
- Yeah, so like the better your hearing is
the higher the frequency.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Generally when you get around to 30,
it starts to get a lot worse.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I mean, like, who the fuck needs to hear
like the high kilohertz?
- I mean, I immediately felt that,
like, 'cause you know, in
like some arcades in Japan
they have mosquito tone
- Yeah, I have that too.
- that like stops like
animals from coming in.
- Oh yeah.
- And every time we
walk past like an arcade
with like a bunch of friends
and they'd be like, "Oh, fuck!"
I'll be like, "What?"
I legitimately don't hear anything.
- It's actually an advantage here.
'Cause Sydney can hear
it and I can't anymore.
Yeah.
- Apparently it hurts.
I'm just like, I don't-
- Apparently like in a
lot of shops in Japan,
they just play this like high,
I can't describe it actually.
- Isn't to stop like teenagers?
Doesn't it stop teenagers
from like loitering.
- [Navi] To stop people
from loitering in front.
- I've also heard it's to
stop birds from flying.
- [Navi] And cats.
- Can you hear it, Connor?
- I can hear it.
- Okay, what does it sound like?
I was gonna describe what it was,
and then I realize that-
- I can't hear it.
- I just realized I've never heard it.
- It's just an uncomfortable
ring in your ear.
- An uncomfortable ring in your ear?
- It doesn't particularly feel good.
It kind of hurts.
I don't know, it just hurts.
- It looks like it hurts.
- That's what it's
designed to do, to hurt.
- But what I don't understand is is that
if they've just put this
high frequency alarm or ring
to stop birds?
Mosquitoes?
- Animals and loitering.
- Oh, okay.
- I don't know which
one it's actually for.
- Is it for humans or animals?
- I don't know.
- Apparently it's for both
'cause humans can hear it as well.
- Probably should have picked
a lower frequency then,
because it doesn't work,
if you've just got shit hearing,
then you're just immune to it.
- It's meaning to stop
like kids loitering.
So, that's the idea.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- I've never been able to hear it though
even when I was a kid.
- Yeah, but you've been
listening to like music for-
- Yeah, I've probably
been to too many concerts
where my years just got fucked.
- You're gonna be like
40 and be like, "What?
"What did you say to me, Garnt?"
- I'm still like that.
- True, you are.
Your hearing is really bad.
- No, but I talked about it
on the podcast, remember?
'Cause when we went to
go do the health checkup,
and I got an aid for my
hearing and then I realized,
oh, I don't have bad
hearing, I just don't listen.
(everyone laughs)
- You're just fucking dumb.
- I just don't care about
what you say sometimes
that I just shut it out.
- True, true, true.
- That's what it is, yeah.
- You boys have any fun
plans for the summer?
- You know what I miss?
This is like the first time in my life
where I've just not lived
near a body of water.
- You're surrounded by water.
What do you mean?
- We're literally an island country.
- No, but, like, we're in Tokyo.
And I think the closest
thing is like Tokyo Bay.
Like, part of the summer
experience for me is
just going to the beach somewhere
and just like having a nice chill,
you know, beer or something.
And haven't been able to do
that for the past two years.
And I've really missed that experience.
- I mean, it doesn't really matter
because like the beaches have
been closed from lockdown.
- Exactly.
It doesn't matter anyway
'cause I can't go to the beaches anyway.
And like Okinawa is on
lockdown, so I can't go there.
So, I just, it doesn't feel like,
I've had the worst part
of the summer experience
which is just the fucking blistering heat.
And haven't been able to
just enjoy the nice parts.
- Trapped in a concrete jungle.
- Yeah, basically.
- So, what are you gonna do
for your summer then, Garnt?
- I don't know.
What can I do for the summer?
- Is there anything fun
you can do in the summer
that doesn't involve a beach
or a pool or any body of water?
- Stay inside and play video games.
- Sounds pretty fucking good.
- That's what you do in
winter though, right?
- Both seasons.
All seasons.
- 'Cause another thing is
that we get mosquitoes here
in Japan and we don't-
- Do we?
- Yeah, we do.
- I haven't seen any.
- Do you not get bitten?
- No.
- Lucky.
- How do you not get bitten?
- I get eaten alive.
- Maybe my blood doesn't taste good.
I don't know.
I've never had a mosquito bite.
- Apparently it does
depend on your blood type.
- Okay, I think it does
because I get bitten to shit
whenever a mosquito's around.
- They don't go for me.
I can be in an area where
someone will get bit a ton,
I won't have any on me.
- I literally-
- God, I wish that was me.
- I literally laid outside on my balcony
for like half an hour,
came inside and I had
like 10 bites on my back.
I'm not even joking.
- I'm exactly the same.
- I don't get bit.
I've never even.
I didn't even know they had them here.
- Yeah 'cause normally-
- I don't get bitten.
- Are you serious?
- Serious.
I thought they didn't have them
here' cause I don't get bit.
- That's another reason
I love British summers is
that we just don't have any
bugs that are annoying because-
- You guys don't have mosquitoes?
- No.
- Do you not remember when
we were just chilling out
in England in my garden?
- I just thought I got lucky.
(everyone laughs)
I just thought like, oh,
there's a stronger blood type
somewhere in the vicinity
that they're going for.
- There's no mosquitoes.
- No, I'm just that guy, 'cause like,
I'm just that guy who like, I'm the bait.
- The meme of like the blades falling down
and the guy covering.
It's Garnt, everyone else at the party.
- Yeah, 'cause like,
if people hang out with me in
Thailand or Japan or whatever,
they get bitten less because I'm there.
I'm the bait.
I am what every mosquito goes
for, and I don't know why.
- Garnt the martyr.
- Because in Thailand we have this saying
where normally it's the mosquitoes
go for the foreign people
because it's the foreign
people who have the sweet blood
because the mosquitoes
aren't used to their blood.
- So that was a lie.
- So that was a fucking lie.
Well, technically I didn't
grow up in Thailand,
so maybe there's some kind of truth to it.
But apparently if you have
never been beaten, well-
- Beaten by a mosquito.
- The mosquito's fucking,
what's going on, huh?
Come in our neighborhood.
I've never get bitten by mosquitoes.
- I'm so fucking jute.
- Is it like a blood type thing?
I don't even remember my-
- Apparently it's like a blood type thing.
It's also like a skin thing as well.
Like, certain skin.
Like, if you have like oily skin,
you're more likely to get bitten.
I don't know.
There's lots of theories out there.
I think it's literally just like,
if you're unlucky, you're
unlucky kind of thing.
- Beer?
Beer?
- Oh yeah, no, apparently
you're more likely to get stung
if you're drunk.
- Is that true?
- Yeah, apparently.
- Does that not make the mosquitoes drunk?
- I don't know.
- That's probably why.
They're like, "Eh, my
guys time for a sesh."
Because they get drunk
off the blood, right?
- Maybe.
I've still never been bitten drinking,
so I don't know what's going on.
- Lads, lads, lads!
- Is there a reason why the
mosquitoes go for people more
or less?
- [Navi] Yeah, there's
like seven reasons why.
- I don't know if any of
that has actually been, like,
scientifically confirmed.
I feel it's just like,
it might be like a
little like coincidence.
- I'm just not tasty enough.
What the fuck?
- [Navi] Might be your blood type as well.
- It's probably blood type.
- What if I'm not tasty?
What?
- I want to be tasty.
- What?
- No, you don't want to be tasty.
- You don't want to be tasty.
- I want to be tasty, that's bullshit.
- Mosquitoes are fucking,
they're the worst.
They're the fucking cunts
of the fucking insect world.
Nobody likes mosquitoes.
There could be like the biggest
animal lover in the world
and they see a mosquito and,
like, fuck that little shit.
- Isn't like the mosquito,
I think I read somewhere,
isn't the mosquito like the only animal
in like the food chain where
if you got rid of them,
it just wouldn't change the food chain?
- I don't know if that's an urban legend,
but I hope it's true.
- I think it's something like
that 'cause I remember seeing,
'cause like I think I looked
it up 'cause I was like,
'cause in Australia we
have a shit ton of flies
during the summer.
Like, it's fucking horrible.
Especially if you're
like out in the desert,
nothing but flies.
It's disgusting.
And I think, I just thought
to myself, like, man,
I really just wish all
flies just disappeared.
And then one of my
friends was like, oh no,
like flies are like really
important to the food chain.
Like, there's a lot of
animals that eat flies.
And thought like, is there
an animal where if we just,
it just disappeared one day,
would the food chain still be intact?
And I think mosquitoes was one of them.
- Humans probably.
- Oh yeah, that too.
(everyone laughs)
- I think they'd be grateful actually.
- Just called myself out there.
(everyone laughs)
- We like to think of that-
- You got me, animals, you got me.
- We're the problem all along.
- We were the virus all along, right?
♪ Do, do, do, do ♪
- But yeah, I mean,
I hope mosquitoes are fucking
useless things because-
- I mean, they just
fucking carry diseases.
Like, that's all they really do.
- All they do is like give
malaria to people, right?
- Amongst other things.
- There's probably one like
really obscure species of spider
or something that could
only feed on mosquitoes
that would die out.
- That is integral to the food chain.
It's always like that.
It's like, no, no, there's one animal
that specifically eats this thing.
- How would you even eradicate mosquitoes?
How would you even go about that?
- I don't know.
Don't ask the Aussie.
They've they've had like
enough problems trying
to eradicate a certain-
- Oh yeah, the cane toad?
- Yeah, yeah.
So we have a lot of sugarcane in Australia
during like the 1800s,
and then cane flies were introduced,
which are these specific breed of flies
that only eat sugarcane
and which completely
wiped out our sugarcane.
And we're like, well, fuck.
We gotta get rid of these flies
because our food is getting fuck up.
And then someone was
like, I've heard overseas,
there was a specific type
of toad called the cane toad
that specifically only eats cane flies.
Someone thought, oh that's brilliant.
That's gonna solve all of our problems.
Let's introduce it.
So, they introduced it.
Yeah, all the cane flies disappeared.
But then somebody realized,
shit, nothing eats cane toads.
And they're literally poisonous,
and they're killing our native animals.
So, now we just have a cane toad outbreak.
- And you just can't get rid of it, right?
- And we just can't get rid of it.
- Dude, it's like me playing chess.
They only thought one move ahead.
They didn't plan anything else.
Like, this feels like a vast oversight
in like possible downsides.
No pros and cons lists.
Someone was like, bro, I
got one, bring it over.
Let's just test it out.
- It sounds like the beginning
of like an "Always Sunny" skit, right?
(Joey laughs)
Like, you're just like, oh,
let's bring over the cane toads.
And you just see like
the fucking intro title.
Gang introduces cane
toads to the food chain.
- And then again, Australia,
hasn't had very much luck with animals.
I mean, we had an emu war and we lost.
- What the fuck is that about?
Like, I hear every Australian say that.
And I'm just like, that just sounds like-
- The great emu wars.
- The dumbest shit ever.
They went to war against emus.
- And they lost?
- And we lost.
- Okay, do you want to explain that?
- Dude, have you seen an emu?
- No.
- They're fucking terrifying.
- Can they kill you?
- Yeah.
It's Australia!
Everything can kill you!
- Should have known that one.
Should have saw that one coming.
- Were they eating crops?
They were ruining crops, right?
- Yeah, they were ruining crops.
And, again, like they kind of
just like overbred themselves
to the point where there
was just a shit ton of emus
and just not enough space.
So, they started invading farmland.
Obviously farmers got pissed off about it,
so they tried to get them out of it.
But obviously it's one man
versus a fucking two and a half meter bird
that can literally just kick
you in the chest and kill you.
So, I think it went on for
like a month or something.
I don't know how long it was.
It was a very short, it
was a very short war.
- They wasted so much money
on like ammunition and time.
- Ammunition?
- Yeah.
- They were shooting them.
Trying to gun them down.
But they could like-
- But the emus were
literally like the Spartans
and they were like,
it was like, we were like Xerxes army
and the emus were the Spartans.
They're like, oh, shit.
- 'Cause they would like,
they were fighting them.
But they would they
just kept getting away.
It was like a "Loony Tunes" skit.
They couldn't kill them.
- It was just like the Benny Hill theme
for like a month straight.
- They had to wait and ambush them.
That's how they-
- Are you serious?
- They travel in flocks.
They go together in flocks,
and they were trying to ambush them.
- And they're also extremely fast.
They can run like 60, 70 Ks an hour.
- The moment they started
opening fire on them,
they just ran away, and they
would only kill like, you know-
- A couple of them maybe.
- But they'd wasted
like 100 grand in ammo.
Like, ammo isn't cheap.
I feel like because we're so used to war,
you think that ammo is like affordable.
Like, ammo is super expensive.
So, they were just wasting
hundreds of thousands of dollars
on bullets.
- Especially when that war was happening,
it was probably even more expensive.
And then one day someone was
like, it's not worth it, is it?
Just wave the white flag.
And then they just retreated and-
- It's embarrassing.
It was like a huge embarrassment.
- So what was the outcome of this war?
- The emus won.
- The emus won and they're
just roaming the land now?
- Yep.
They just failed miserably.
- What is going on in Australia?
- I'm sure everyone who's
watched internet videos has heard
about this.
This is a very internet video topic.
- It sounds like an Internet
Historian skit, you know.
- I'm surprised he hasn't
made a video on it yet
to be honest.
It's great material.
- Yeah, I mean, it sounds like
on the same level as like,
you know, the 4chan Tumblr
wars or something like that.
(everyone laughs)
We need an Internet Historian breakdown.
- It just doesn't sound
like it really happened.
- It just feels like the laziest
strategy of killing them.
You know?
- There were people who died as well
during the great emu war.
- I just feel like nobody
thought this plan through.
Surely there was a better
way of getting them.
You know what I mean?
Like, that's what pisses me off the most.
It was the laziest solution.
They're like, "Firing squad.
And they were like, "Yeah, okay."
Like, nobody thought, "Is
this really the best idea?"
- Because someone probably took one look
at the fucking shotgun they
had and they were like,
"We got this.
"Easy dub."
- We need a fucking
Hollywood breakdown on this.
Where's the Hollywood summer blockbuster
of the Australian emu war?
Come on, come on.
Come on, Hollywood, get it together.
There's a storyline there somewhere.
- Man versus emu.
- Zack Snyder, come on.
This is the next Zack Snyder film.
(everyone laughs)
- It's like a 300 spinoff.
- It's like "Planet of the Apes"
from the perspective of the emus.
- Planet of the Emus.
- Emus together strong.
I would watch it.
Yeah, it's about the emus winning.
Perspective of the emus.
One of them voiced by Raymond
from "Everyone Loves Raymond."
- Get back Nicholas Cage, come on.
- Yeah, Nicholas Cage is the main role.
And the supporting role is Raymond.
- And he goes insane as the emus win.
(everyone laughs)
- There's a part where Raymond dies,
you know, gets shot and then Nicholas-
- Nicholas Cage loses his mind.
- He was freaking out.
"I can't go on," but he has to.
- Oh my God.
- And ends with a
climatic scene where they-
- What's the summer
experience in Australia?
'Cause like Australia,
it's like winter there.
- Christmas.
- Like, I always here about
like summer is like winter
in Australia.
But like what is winter for Australia?
Is it actually cold?
Or-
- Do you like swap them?
Do you just refer to our summer as winter?
- No.
- Like July?
Is July winter?
- July is the coldest
time of year in Australia.
- But is it winter?
Is July winter?
- It depends where you are.
So in Sydney, it doesn't
get cold enough to snow.
But if you drive for like
two hours into Cambra,
it snows like a motherfucker.
- I have been always under the impression
no matter the temperature that
winter is the time of year.
Like, winter is always
November to January.
Sorry, sorry, November to February.
That is winter.
Is it the same in Australia
where you would refer
to that period as winter?
- No, that's summer.
- But everyone else around you is-
- The hottest day of any year
is always New Year's Eve.
- I always thought that it was like,
okay, no matter what country
you're in, this is winter.
- Yeah, that's what I thought as well.
- It doesn't matter if the temperature-
- What are you talking about?
Winter is the coldest time of year.
For us that's May to August.
- Yeah, I know.
I just thought that winter as
a concept was a time period
not the season.
- No, it's definitely a season for us.
Because like, at least from my memory,
the hottest day of any
year is always the last day
of the year.
So, our family always used to
go to that one mate's place
who had that giant swimming
pool in his backyard
because you're in that pool
'til about two in the morning
'cause it's so fucking hot.
I remember the hottest experience
I've ever had in my life,
it was New Year's Eve,
and it was 45 degrees.
Obviously 45 degrees,
everyone's in the pool.
Even after the sun went
down, it was like 41 degrees.
And it was so hot that I
remember I went home like
that morning, it was like 5:00 AM,
and the fridge had just
exploded from the heat.
Like, the fridge just stopped working.
- The fridge is like,
all right guys, I'm out.
Have a nice day.
- The fridge is like.
Happy new year, lads.
- My final message to the world.
- So, I remember when my
parents got super pissed off
because they just like
literally first day of the year,
they went to the electronics
store and bought a new fridge
because it just got busted from the heat.
- The fridge is one of
those appliances though
that I'd be excited to get a new one.
I'd be like, wow, we can really mix it up
with the fridge this time.
- Well, yeah, but like, you know,
I think it's good when
you can buy a fridge
on your own accord.
- I disagree.
I prefer it when my appliances break
'cause then I'm like, oh,
I have to spend money.
- Oh, woe is me.
- I guess I have to get the
most expensive one, geez.
But when you're upgrading,
you're like, oh, fuck.
I've got a perfectly good one.
I don't really need...
- You start with a cockroach fridge
or washing machine or
whatever or whatever it is.
- Because if it was a good appliance-
- Your standard of an
upgrade is quite low.
(everyone laughs)
We're going from cockroaches
to no cockroaches.
- It's all uphill from there.
- There's some appliances where I'm like,
it literally doesn't need anything fancy.
Like, a microwave does
not need to be fancy.
A microwave just heats.
Heat thing up good, thank you.
- It literally vibrates water molecules.
Literally how would you
do that differently?
- Because I'm using Joey's old one.
'Cause Joey just gave me his one
'cause he wanted to get an-
- Microwave oven,
- Microwave oven, which
I don't believe in.
I think that's nonsense.
- Yeah, I got the kettle from Joey.
When did Joey give you the microwave?
Was it when you moved here?
- Why do you guys keep
taking my hand me downs?
- 'Cause you were like,
"Do you want a microwave?"
And I was like, "Sure."
- 'Cause I remember when,
'cause this was literally
in the first week
when we moved here and we
were just like settling in,
whatever, and you were just like,
"Oh, do you want a kettle?
"You can have a free kettle."
- They were making it out to be a gift.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Fuck off, this is not a gift.
This is not a gift.
- I remember thinking at the time,
"Oh my God, such a good mate.
"He's just helping me.
"Like, he's just helping
me like decorate the house
"and give me appliances."
- I was using those oldest sibling skills.
- 'Cause I remember Aki was like,
"Do you want to just take the microwave?"
I was like, "Why, why would I,
"why were you saying that?
"Why would I just take the microwave?"
They're like, "Oh, like a gift."
And I'm like, "It's not a fucking gift."
(everyone laughs)
I'll take it, but don't
preface that it's a gift.
- Because we were gonna buy an oven.
- Yeah, you wanted to.
- And then we realized,
oh, it's not just an oven.
It's a microwave oven.
- I remember that Aki
was like, "It's a gift."
(everyone laughs)
It's not a gift, it's not a gift.
- Now living in Japan,
I know getting rid of appliances
is a fucking nightmare.
- It's the worst.
- It's a fucking nightmare.
So I'm just like,
that motherfucker just wanted
to get rid of his appliances
that he wants to replace and
he framed it as a fucking gift.
- Welcome to Japan, here's the
kettle I don't use anymore.
- Here you go.
I'm such a good mate.
I'm literally giving you free stuff.
- You're British, you like kettles, right?
- I do, I do.
Actually don't use my kettle anymore.
I use the hot pot thing.
Like thermos pot, whatever it's called.
- Thermo pot?
- Where you just put like
two liters of water in a pot
and it keeps it boiling the whole day.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's more energy efficient.
- Ooh, fancy.
- But yeah, in Japan,
if you want to get rid of your appliances,
this is something that you
should definitely be aware of,
because if it's over like,
if it's a big appliance,
so like I think a hairdryer
or bigger is considered
as a big appliance, you have to call-
- So, literally all appliances.
- Literally any appliance.
- You have to call up the
local government in your area
and tell them you want to get rid of it
and then you have to schedule it, right?
- I actually just finished
doing that the other day
'cause we had to get rid
of our old dining table
and our old like cabinet that
had all of our dishes in it.
- Wait, why didn't your
old moving company do it?
Why didn't you have a
moving company do it?
- We just kind of forgot it.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
We just kind of forgot.
'Cause I originally wanted to,
I originally had the old
kitchen table that we have
on my balcony because I thought,
oh, I could use this
if I'm like barbecuing
or doing something outside
and I need something to like place it on.
But then I kind of didn't use
it, it got hit in the rain,
I forgot to put like a lacquer on it,
so it just started rotting.
And I was like, all right,
need to get rid of this now.
And it was, oh my God-
- Dining tables do that
if you put them outside.
- Yeah.
But it's cool though because in my area
that you can like register
it through like line.
- Oh, that's cool.
- But the sucky thing is had
to wait about, I don't know,
four weeks to throw it out.
'Cause they were like,
"Oh, you have to schedule
it ahead of time."
And I'm like, "Oh, okay."
- Four weeks to throw things out.
- Maybe it's like next
week or like this weekend
or something, you know, whatever.
It's like, "So yeah,
"the next open slot is 40 days from now."
- And you have to give them
the precise measurements
of the thing.
- Yeah.
- I mean, it's obviously I understand why,
but it's one of those
things where it's like,
this is a hassle that I've never
had to do in the UK before.
- Yeah, it's like why
am I measuring something
that I'm about to throw out?
It just doesn't make,
it's a bit ass backwards.
- Yeah, I made sure the
moving company that I've hired
for my place, I'm like, "You
throw things away, right?
"You throw them away?"
- Good thing about like
things like fridges
or like washing machines
and stuff like that is
that like there is usually service where,
when they bring the new
one, they take away the old.
- That's true, that's true.
- Like, we just got a
new washing machine and-
- They take away the old one.
- And they take away the old.
I was like, oh thank God.
- Yeah.
That's why, you know,
whoever sold you the
fucking cockroach fridge,
they were just like, man.
They were like 500 IQ.
"We got him to pay for this shit.
"We got him to pay for this."
- I got scammed.
That was a scam.
- Straight up scam.
- First time in Japan.
I got a gift.
- Welcome to Japan.
- What a warm greeting
to a foreign country.
But yeah, I made sure
the movie company like,
"You throw things away, right?"
And I was like, "Great.
"Everything needs to go.
"Get rid of everything."
I'm literally throwing away
like nearly everything I own.
- It's time for an upgrade.
- 'Cause I'm like, yeah, 'cause
my bed was like 200 bucks
for like the bed and the mattress.
It's fucking terrible.
It's like, I'm sure like, you know,
prisoners in isolation get
better beds than what I've got.
So I was like, you know, get rid of it.
- They get a whole padded room.
- It's an absolute nightmare.
'Cause yeah (laughs)
Get the whole sound proofing too.
'Cause if you want to do it myself,
I have to disassemble the
bed and then like put it down
into the thing, schedule when
they're gonna come get it,
and then kind of like schedule
getting a new bed myself
in between the day I'm throwing it out.
It's a real nightmare.
- Yeah, yeah.
That was a nightmare for us.
And that's why like when we
moved into our new place,
'cause we threw our old bed away,
when we were waiting for the new bed,
we had to sleep on like a
fucking blow up mattress
for like a week.
- Oh wow.
- Just because the timing was off.
But like yeah, because I'm
thinking of like getting rid
of my desk in my place.
- Oh, 'cause you're thinking
about getting the standing desk.
- I'm just dreading
having to like schedule a,
I have to wait another month
to like throw this thing out,
and then I have to take it
down myself and disassemble it.
I'm just like (groans)
- It's a pain in the ass.
- It sucks.
Please make it better.
- You can get a service, right?
- That's what I'm thinking.
I'm just gonna like, I'm
just gonna pay the money.
Just get someone to just
come and get rid of it.
- If you want to get
rid of your appliances,
it's probably gonna take like
all day just to sort out.
- Yeah, I mean, if you can make, you know,
it's probably what?
An hour to disassemble?
Then you gotta fuck around
with the calling the people,
taking it down,
figuring out when you
got to do all that stuff.
Like, it's probably what?
Three hours of work?
You can probably make more
than the money it would cost
to do that if you just worked.
So it's like I would rather,
'cause I also don't,
it's sometimes not even
the money it's, like,
I don't want to deal with the stress.
Like, this is a stressful thing
that I don't like dealing with.
And so I will pay a premium
to not have to do that.
- Not only that,
but like I have to deal with
it in this weather as well.
It's like, fuck that.
Disassembling that dining
table in this heat was hell.
- I like fixing my electronics
and like opening them up
and doing that stuff, 'cause I enjoy that,
but I don't enjoy disassembling
furniture and desks.
- I don't think anyone does.
- I like assembling furniture.
I don't like disassembling furniture.
- Some people are like
so good with that stuff
and they enjoy it.
They just like.
- But like disassembling furniture is
like the most depressing
thing in the world.
'Cause like at least if
you're assembling furniture,
you have something to look forward to.
You get the final product.
What are you looking forward to
after disassembling the furniture?
Nothing.
- That's why in the UK,
I used to just put it on like websites
and I'd be like, "Who wants it for free?"
- We used a service for that
when we moved to get rid of our couch.
- Yeah, I'm like, "Who wants it?"
- We just like, there's a
website where you can just like,
just put it up for like zero yen.
It's like, "Come and get it."
And some dude came to get it.
- Yeah, as long as you take
it away, you deal with it,
you can have it.
That's what I did in the
UK with all the stuff.
Like, I had a budget gaming
chair that was just broken.
I was like, "Oh, if someone
wants it, you gonna have it.
"It's kinda jank.
"It still works, but it's not great."
And then someone just came.
Some Russian guy turned up to my door.
"My son will love this chair."
And I was like, all right, cool.
- Yeah, I just don't want
to do anything in this heat.
Like, if I'm not inside in
an air conditioned place,
then I just don't want to be there.
Like, me and Sydney tried
to like schedule a date
the other day where we just
go out and do something
and then we realized we just don't want
to fucking do anything outside.
Let's just try and find something inside
because it's literally
impossible to do anything.
And especially now with
inside activities kind of
on lockdown, it's really hard
to find anything right now.
- Exactly.
- True, true.
Amen to that.
- You know who else hates the summer heat?
Our patrons.
- Ooh.
- Probably, I don't know.
(everyone laughs)
Actually, if our patrons were here,
they would definitely hate summer.
- They would hate summer.
If you're British, I don't
know if you hate summer or not.
- I can't stand this.
- I didn't until I moved outside.
And now I hate the summer.
Not as much as the winter though.
Winter sucks.
- Doesn't help that we
record "Trash Taste"
with these blasting lights on us.
- I was sweating a lot of this episode
because we didn't turn
on the air conditioning
in this fucking heat.
- As you were talking earlier,
I could literally see
a giant bead of sweat.
- It's 'cause I've got the
fucking sun staring at me
and we don't even fucking have the AC on.
- The price that we, you know,
you can't say that we
don't care about you guys.
- Meilyne gave me the Evian facial spray
which I actually accepted.
And I realize that it did nothing.
- How the tables have turned.
- We suffer to make good
content for you guys.
- So, if you'd like to
support our suffering,
then make sure to go to our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us the memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
- Yeah, and I guess that's this episode,
this summery themed episode
of "Trash Taste," I suppose.
Was it summery themed?
- Well, you're dressed for the occasion.
- I, you know-
- You're so dressed well for the occasion.
- I'm gonna start a barbecue after this.
(everyone laughs)
- Very dad of you.
- Yeah, but anyway,
that's been this episode of "Trash Taste."
Hope you enjoy your summer, and
we'll see you all next time.
Bye!
- Bye!
(chill music plays)